Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 41. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe über Wissenschaft und wissenschaftliche Arbeit. Und wir haben ja hier in den letzten Wochen und Monaten und mittlerweile ja auch Jahren schon so einige Disziplinen des wissenschaftlichen Betriebs vorgestellt bzw. auch mal reimgeschnuppert, wie denn die wissenschaftliche Welt aus der Perspektive aussieht. Und so eine Sendung haben wir heute auch wieder und tauchen ganz tief ein in die Geschichte. Aber nicht in die Wissenschaftsgeschichte als solche, wie wir das gemacht haben, sondern so ein bisschen die Wissenschaft der Geschichte, ganz konkret soll es gehen um Archäologie und dazu begrüße ich meine Gesprächspartnerin, Monika Trümper, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Frau Trümper Sie sind Professorin, wie heißt es so schön, für klassische Archäologie an der FU in Berlin, der freien Universität in Berlin. Gibt es noch andere Archäologien außer der klassischen?
Oh ja, es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Archäologien, die normalerweise nach Epochen benannt werden, also konkret an der FU gibt es zunächst die prähistorische Archäologie und dann die vorderasiatische Archäologie. Dann gibt es die Ägyptologie, die häufig eben auch archäologisch arbeitet und Sie könnten die Altamerikanistik nehmen, die mittelamerikanische Archäologie und so weiter. Also es gibt, letztendlich könnte man sagen, für jede Kultur gibt es Archäologien.
Das heißt das ist im wesentlichen ortsbezogen?
Ortsbezogen ja. Also zunächst ist ja Archäologie einfach könnte man sagen eine Wissenschaft oder Methode, die sich für jede Gesellschaft anwenden lässt bis ins 19. Jahrhundert. Deswegen ist es jetzt klassische Archäologie, die ist natürlich griechisch-römisch, aber es gibt x-dutzend anderer Archäologien.
Okay, aber hier geht es im Wesentlichen ums Mittelmeer kann man sagen?
Ums Mittelmeer richtig.
Bevor wir vielleicht darauf kommen, würde mich natürlich interessieren, wie Sie da eigentlich selber drauf gekommen sind. Waren Sie denn schon immer so auf dem Trip, irgendwie ja so Wissenschaft das ist mein Ding oder haben Sie erst mal eine Sportkarriere eingeschlagen?
Sportkarriere nicht gerade. Also ich würde sagen, in der Schule so in der Oberstufe zeichnete sich schon Interesse ab für Kultur/Kunst im weitesten Sinne. Ich hatte Geschichte und Latein als Leistungskurse, die gab es damals noch. Aber dann habe ich zunächst einen Umweg über eine andere Leidenschaft genommen. Ich habe Musik studiert, Geige und das auch abgeschlossen und war dort auch beruflich tätig. Dann allerdings doch relativ schnell gemerkt, dass das nicht das ist, was ich mein Leben lang vielleicht machen möchte und habe parallel während des Musikstudiums schon begonnen an der Universität damals in Köln zu studieren. Meinen Neigungen aus der Schule folgend. Ich bin auch sehr viel gereist mit meinen Eltern. Also ich kannte mich durchaus gut aus, vor allen Dingen in Italien in verschiedenen Perioden und Epochen und habe dann Kunstgeschichte und klassische Archäologie und zunächst Italienisch, später alte Geschichte, studiert. Und relativ schnell hat sich dann abgezeichnet, dass die klassische Archäologie wirklich das ist, was mich wissenschaftlich am meisten fasziniert.
Zunächst sage ich mal ohne konkrete Berufsperspektiven, das war ein gewisser Luxus, den ich mir leisten konnte, denn ich hatte ja immer die Musik im Hintergrund. Habe da damals auch recht gut verdient. Also ich habe unterrichtet oder mit Orchestern, mit kleineren, gespielt. Konnte mich auch selbst finanzieren, von daher hatte ich nicht diesen Druck unbedingt, das als Beruf zunächst anvisieren zu müssen. Aber je weiter ich dann fortgeschritten bin mit Magister und Dissertation, zeichnete sich das dann doch irgendwann ab, dass ich das beruflich machen möchte.
Okay also man finanziert sich sozusagen sein Studium mit brotloser Kunst.
Naja es war ja mein Zweitstudium. Das Erststudium haben mir generös meine Eltern finanziert, die haben mich dann durchaus auch weiter unterstützt und ich war in verschiedenen Stiftungen, also das ging alles. Aber die Musik war so eine Art Fallback-Solution.
Okay, aber Sie sind mit einer gewissen Ruhe da sozusagen rangegangen.
Ja.
Und haben sich eigentlich so ein bisschen von dem Reiz der Disziplin locken und leiten lassen?
Ja ganz sicherlich.
Und was ist der Reiz?
Die unglaubliche Vielfältigkeit. Also klassische Archäologie ist vielfältig anschlussfähig. Wie sehr, das weiß man vielleicht nicht direkt am Anfang, wenn man das studiert, aber zunehmend und ich denke einmal mehr heute erfahren das Studenten viel früher als noch zu meiner Zeit. Man kann quasi mehr in die ausgrabungstechnische Seite gehen. Man kann sehr viel mit Naturwissenschaften machen, bis hin sage ich mal zu einer sehr stark kunsthistorischen Seite, wo man mit der Kunstgeschichte oder auch mit Literaturwissenschaften, Philologien zusammenarbeitet. Es gibt eben eine ganze Bandbreite, weil die klassische Archäologie heute die gesamte materielle Kultur der Antike untersucht. Früher war der Schwerpunkt vielleicht mehr tatsächlich auf Skulpturen und Bildern und vielleicht Tempel, was wir so als Hochkultur bezeichnen, heute ist es tatsächlich bis hin zu den Löffeln oder Webgewichten, die sie ausgraben. Also ein sehr viel breiterer Zugang zu Kultur, materieller Kultur im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Und das macht es auch extrem reizvoll. Und hinzu kommt, früher war der Schwerpunkt sag ich mal mehr chronologisch auch wieder auf dem, was man als die Blüte der Kultur bezeichnen konnte. Also etwa Athen im 5. Jahrhundert oder 6./5./4. Jahrhundert und Rom. Heute hat man ein sehr viel breiteres Verständnis chronologisch und auch geografisch und nimmt also viele Randkulturen – schon der Begriff ist etwas fragwürdig – mit, also zum Beispiel Phönizier oder Skythen. Also man weitet die Perspektive extrem aus.
Skythen?
mhm (bejahend).
Wo haben die denn gelebt?
Ja am schwarzen Meer.
Noch nie gehört.
Ja doch faszinierend.
Ja glaube ich sofort. Gut das kommt ja auch nicht täglich vor. Klar die Griechen und Phönizier, das hat man schon mal gehört, zumindest wenn man viel Asterix gelesen hat, da ist man ja dann auch so halbwegs im Bilde.
Ja richtig. Die sind auch toll, kann man nur empfehlen.
Ja hat sicherlich da für eine Menge Verständnis beigetragen. Sie haben gerade das Wort anschlussfähig benutzt. Also anschlussfähig inwiefern? Also anschlussfähig in andere Disziplinen hinein, meinten Sie das?
Ja in jedem Fall. Also anschlussfähig … wir zum Beispiel an der FU haben ein Bachelorprogramm, was die fünf verschiedenen Archäologien oder Fächer miteinander kombiniert. Also da hat man schon die Breite in der Antike. Und anschlussfähig, wie ich eben sagte, das ist jetzt etwas, was vor allen Dingen im Exzellenzcluster Topoi auch sehr stark zur Sprache kommt, in vielfältige andere Disziplinen. Zum Beispiel wenn man klassische Archäologie mehr mit Feldforschung macht, dann bietet es sich sehr an mit der physischen Geografie oder mit der Geoarchäologie zusammenzuarbeiten oder mit Umweltarchäologie, also mit zahlreichen naturwissenschaftlichen Methoden, die uns helfen viel besser zu verstehen, was wir ausgraben. Das sind mittlerweile solche Spezialkenntnisse, die können sie gar nicht alleine liefern und leisten als klassischer Archäologe. Oder es gibt vielfältige mittlerweile digitale Dokumentationsmethoden. Faszinierende Sachen, für die man eben auch wirklich die Kollegen braucht.
Oder ich sagte auf der andren Seite, wenn Sie tatsächlich ein großes Interesse an der Bildwissenschaft haben, dann können Sie sich Ihren Kollegen aus der Kunstgeschichte oder mit den Kollegen aus der Literaturwissenschaft, den Philologien eben bestens kombinieren und unterhalten.
Das heißt es ist ein sehr interdisziplinäres Fach, was vielleicht erst mal gar nicht so in dem Ruf steht, ein solches zu sein?
Ja, aber ehrlich gestanden, das ist es immer gewesen. Also die Frage natürlich, wie man interdisziplinär formuliert. Im 19. Jahrhundert etwa konnten die Forscher alle die antiken Sprachen rauf und runter. Die kannten also das, was wir heute alte Geschichte, Gräzistik und Latinistik kennen und haben die materielle Kultur mitgenommen und kannten die kunsthistorischen Methoden, die theoretischen Methoden. Das heißt ich würde sagen, das Fach war per sé immer interdisziplinär. Da ist die Frage, wo Sie den Schwerpunkt legen, hinzugekommen. Ist ganz sicherlich, das liegt natürlich in der Natur der Sache der Entwicklung von Technologie und Wissenschaften, der mehr naturwissenschaftliche Schwerpunkt. Aber es hat bereits in den 1970ern, etwa da wo ich grabe, auch Naturwissenschaften und Geophysik gegeben. Manche waren da sehr früh Vorreiter.
Naturwissenschaften …
Also Untersuchungsmethoden, die man eben aus den anderen Disziplinen hergenommen hat, hat die Archäologie eigentlich relativ früh angewendet. Luftbildarchäologie.
Ah okay. Und auch sozusagen Schichtenwissen, wo finde ich jetzt eigentlich was, was bedeutet das.
Oder die Analyse etwa von, wenn Sie graben, Analyse organischer Hinterlassenschaften. Die Analyse von Erde, die Analyse von Steinen, also es gibt vielfältige Beispiele, wo die Archäologie sehr früh sich eben anderer Disziplinen bedient hat. Also es ist keine Orchideenwissenschaft, wenn Sie so wollen.
Ja, aber ich würde auch mal die These aufstellen, dass sich die Arbeit der Archäologie auch extrem, wie das ja eigentlich für viele Wissenschaften gilt, aber in gewisser Hinsicht hier auch nochmal vieles neu aufgerollt worden ist. Ich erfinde jetzt mal so einen Zahl, in den letzten 30 Jahren so die Bestimmung von Objekten, wie alt die sind, durch moderne Methodiken. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht genau, wie die Geräte heißen, die da primär zum Einsatz kommen.
Sie können Thermolumineszenz oder C14-Methoden. Es gibt zahlreiche Methoden.
Über Zerfallsprozesse zum Beispiel genau.
Ja.
Also das sind ja alles Dinge, die haben ja im Prinzip eine komplett neue Tür aufgemacht und wahrscheinlich auch tatsächlich die Tür zu den Archiven insofern neu geöffnet, als dass man alles nochmal rausgeholt hat, von dem man so dachte, da hat man jetzt schon mal alles abgestaubt und jetzt konnte man einfach auch nochmal einen komplett neuen Blick darauf richten, ist richtig oder?
Ja das stimmt schon. Also ich meine die Archäologie hat sich immer weiterentwickelt und muss sich immer weiterentwickeln und man ist einfach smart und gut bedient, wenn man sich umguckt, was gerade zur Verfügung steht, um das Fach weiter zu entwickeln. Wie gesagt, C14 hat es auch schon lange gegeben, aber heute gibt es zusätzliche andere Methoden, gerade in den Keramikanalysen, das ist jetzt nicht ganz mein Spezialgebiet, aber kann man die Rückstände etwa in Gefäßen untersuchen, um herauszufinden, was darin gelagert wurde, was die Leute gegessen haben, also solche Analysen schreiten permanent fort. Eine der ganz großen neuen Geschichten sind etwa DNA-Analysen, die jetzt zunehmend eben auch angewendet werden in der Archäologie, da gibt es sicherlich ganz aufregende neue Entwicklungen. Und gerade sehr stark auch in der digitalen Dokumentation. Das klingt zunächst nur, ja gut wir wenden das an und dann sieht das Foto irgendwie hübscher aus, aber es gibt da tatsächlich neue Erkenntnisse.
Also man kann ganz anders graben, man kann tatsächlich während des Grabungsprozesses etwa quasi 3D abbilden, wo man bestimmte Kontexte und Schichten ausgräbt und das hinterher eben auch visualisieren und viel besser nachvollziehen, wie man das zu interpretieren hat. Also da gibt es wie gesagt aufregende Verbindungen zwischen Archäologie und anderen Disziplinen und Technik.
Ja, weil man auch einfach … also interpretiere ich das richtig, ist eine andere Form auch des Dokumentierens.
Ja in jedem Fall.
Also man schafft sozusagen, ich meine ich stelle mir jetzt mal vor, keine Ahnung, nehmen wir mal an, morgen stolpert irgendeiner in Baden-Württemberg im Wald über eine Sandale und man stellt fest, holla hier gab es ja mal eine Schlacht, ist ja auch tatsächlich passiert so in den letzten Jahren, habe ich zumindest von gelesen, dass so neue Schlachtfelder gefunden wurden und dann kommt halt so die Armada der Archäologen mit spitzen Messern und schabt dann halt wirklich so Millimeter für Millimeter von diesem Berg runter. Und die gesamte Konstellation dessen, was liegt wo worunter, worüber, wie tief etc., woraus ist das gemacht, bietet ja die Möglichkeit, im Prinzip eine komplette Geschichtserzählung auch vollständig anders zu erzählen oder überhaupt erst anders zu verstehen. Und ich weiß nicht, heute fährt man da wahrscheinlich schon gleich mit einem Laserscanner hin, bevor man irgendwie überhaupt irgendwas aus dem Boden herausnimmt, um einfach zu sehen, wie die Situation ist oder?
Ja ganz sicher. Also man hat heute auf der einen Seite viel weniger Zeit als früher, um zu graben und eben nicht mehr Heerscharen von Arbeitern, die schlicht die Erde wegschaffen. Also die ganzen Konditionen fürs Graben haben sich geändert, aber natürlich auch die Fragestellung und der Anspruch, was man dokumentiert. Also früher hat man sich für viele Details nicht interessiert, die man heute eben erforschen will. Und es gibt man kann sagen einerseits eine Art Standardprogramm, das man heute bei den meisten Grabungen fährt, andererseits muss man immer gucken, was jetzt gerade die Stätte bietet, was geboten ist, was angesagt ist, was die Finanzierung ist, muss man auch klipp und klar sagen, was das Zeitfenster ist, was man zur Verfügung hat. Aber etwa tatsächlich fängt man heute nicht sofort an zu graben oft, man macht sehr häufig Surveys verschiedene. Also einmal den geophysikalischen, den ich erwähnte, das ist eine aufregende Entwicklung vielleicht der späten 80er, frühen 90ern, da war das so Vorreiterrolle. Troja war eines der ersten was erforscht wurde.
Und man guckt gewissermaßen mit verschiedenen Techniken in den Boden rein und versucht festzustellen, also etwa, ob da eine Stadtanlage ist, wie die Stadtanlage geplant ist, ob man besonders interessante Bauten identifizieren kann, die man gezielt graben möchte. Also man großflächig zunächst erforschen und dann versuchen, sehr viel gezielter nachzugraben. Da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten und man kann das mit Luftbild machen, mit verschiedenen Technologien, aber die Idee ist immer erst mal nicht invasiv, sehr großflächig erste Aussagen zu bekommen. Was Sie damit nicht können, a) es ist nicht immer 100% sicher. Es gibt also bei Nachgrabungen durchaus auch böse Überraschungen oder Überraschungen neutraler Art und Sie bekommen dadurch nie eine Datierung, die wir als Archäologen oder auch Historiker immer brauchen. Sie kriegen dadurch auch keine chronologische Abfolge und Entwicklung, Sie kriegen ein gewisses Bild, so eine Art Ist-Zustand.
Dann gibt es andere Survey-Methoden, wo man tatsächlich übers Feld läuft und Artefakte kartiert oder vielleicht auch aufsammelt und bestimmt. Auch das eine eher rezentere Methode, die die klassischen Archäologen in Deutschland zunächst gar nicht also angewendet haben und auch nicht populär fanden. Das waren eher die Historiker, die geografische Landeskunde machten. Und die hatten große landschaftshistorische Fragestellungen, wenn Sie so wollen und haben das also initiiert. Und man kann recht grob, also zum Beispiel Siedlungsmuster, wo ist überhaupt großflächig im Hinterland von einer Stadt, wo sind da Siedlungsreste nachzuweisen, also eine ganze Reihe von interessanten Fragestellungen, die gucken auch sehr stark nach dem Terrain, nach der Topografie, wie das aussieht. Das ist eine Methode und dann können Sie natürlich gezielt ans Graben gehen. Und wenn Sie dann graben ist invasiv, wie man so schön sagt, potenziell zerstörend, weil Sie ja Schichten abtragen und unwiederbringlich sind die Sachen verloren. Und da kann man heute mit den Grabungsmethoden oder auch mit den Dokumentationsmethoden eben quasi versuchen, das optimal zu rekonstruieren oder zu modellieren, dass man es nachvollziehen kann.
Also wunderbare Methoden, Structure from Motion, das kennen viele Leute privat, wo sie quasi Fotomosaike zusammenstellen und relativ schnell und einfach 3D-Ansichten bekommen. Das können Sie quasi georeferenziert entzerrt machen, aber auch schon ganz einfach mit simplen Online-Programmen, die kostenlos verfügbar sind. Und 3D-Laserscanning macht man natürlich auch und Drohnen und ähnliche andere Methoden kann man alle einsetzen, um optimal zu dokumentieren.
Also Structure from Motion das ist so diese, also man nimmt quasi Bewegtbild, ein Video und baut darauf die 3dimensionalen Modelle zusammen?
Nein nicht ganz. Also Sie machen von einem Objekt oder ich sage mal, wir machen das eben auf der Grabung von unseren Schnitten oder auch von archäologischen Resten, die wir haben, machen Sie so viele Fotos wie möglich aus unterschiedlichen Winkeln und Ansichten. Also von allen Seiten. Wenn Sie quasi 3D, wenn Sie so ein Objekt haben, machen Sie es von allen Seiten, oben, unten und dann gibt es professionelle Programme, wir benutzen jetzt dieses Archisoft zum Beispiel, dem Sie das eingeben und in einem Verfahren, das ist etwas kompliziert mit Clouds und wird dann gewissermaßen dieses Objekt aus diesen Fotos zusammengesetzt und Sie kriegen es dann als drehbares Bild.
Das ist im Prinzip dieselbe Technik, die bei GoogleEarth, AppleMaps etc. eingesetzt wird, um halt so die 3-dimensionalen Abbilder der Städte zu haben, aber das kann man natürlich auch für kleinere Objekte genauso verwenden.
Sie können es für Objekte verwenden. Sie können es eben für Befunde verwenden, für alles mögliche. Und Sie können wie gesagt sogar, wenn Sie eben feste georeferenzierte Punkte haben, dann können Sie davon gewissermaßen sogar abzeichnen hinterher 1:1, das machen viele. Die zeichnen gar nicht mehr von Hand vor Ort, sondern machen eben Structure from Motion oder Photogrammetrie, das sind andere Dokumentationsmethoden, die funktionieren letztendlich alle relativ ähnlich. Und die sind so genau und so schnell im Vergleich etwa zu jemandem, der noch von Hand zeichnen muss. Dass sie natürlich auf der Grabung auch optimal für die Zeitökonomie sind.
Weil das ja jetzt eigentlich gar nicht mal mehr nur so für die Arbeit an sich hilfreich ist, das natürlich auch. Wie ich mir jetzt gerade vorstellen, wagen wir zum Beispiel den Blick nach Syrien, was ja nun wirklich eine … da kommen Sie schon ins schwere Atmen, ich glaube für Archäologen ist das nochmal doppelt schlimm. Ich meine schlimm genug, was dort passiert ist in den letzten fünf Jahren, aber was dort natürlich auch verloren gegangen ist, nicht nur jetzt an potenziellen Forschungsorten, sondern auch einfach schon an gewonnenen Dingen. Worauf ich hinaus will ist, diese neue Kartografierung und 3-dimensionale Untersuchung etc. schafft ja auch digitale Archive, die besser rettbar und in die Zukunft trinkbar sind, als reine Sammlungen. Das sollte sozusagen generell eigentlich ein Trend sein, dass man auch das, was man schon hat, so neu erfasst oder?
Ja, im Idealfall ja. Da träumen wir alle von. Ich sehe es mit gewisser, also einerseits Begeisterung, andererseits Skepsis. Begeisterung weil, also zumindest auf meinen Grabungen, die Ergebnisse sind da fantastisch und wenn an den Bau kennt, dann sieht man, wie anschaulich die wirklich sind etwa. Großes Problem denke ich und das realisieren alle, die mit diesen Technologien arbeiten, ist die Frage der Archivierung tatsächlich, wo und wie archivieren wir das eigentlich. Also jetzt liegt es irgendwie bei mir auf meinem external Harddrive oder auf meiner Festplatte, nein die ist immer schon voll. Und dann ist schon die Frage, gibt es irgendwie ein Backup in der Cloud vom Universitätsserver. Und dann ist die Frage, okay was ist eigentlich in 20-30 Jahren damit, wer kann das noch sehen? Oder wer macht permanente Updates, das ist ein ganz ganz großes Problem im Moment der Langzeitarchivierung, physisch oder wer verwaltet das und wer garantiert, dass ich das in 10-20-30-50 Jahren ebenfalls auch noch angucken kann.
Das ist der eine Faktor. Der andere ist nach wie vor bei diesem Structure from Motion, wenn Sie das in hoher Qualität haben, das crasht schon meinen Rechner, das kann ich mir nicht angucken. Das heißt Sie brauchen eigentlich hochleistungsstarke Rechner oder sie müssen es wieder auf eine Qualität runterfahren, die, okay Sie wollen jetzt mal dem generellen Publikum Ihre Modelle zeigen, dann mag das reichen, aber fürs Wissenschaftliche wollen Sie ja eigentlich die hochauflösende Form haben. Also da müssen noch technologische Revolutionen passieren, die bezahlbar sind, bevor wir wirklich alle Benefits dieser neuen Technologie wirklich nutzen können. Und von daher mit Skepsis. Und ich sage, was man gedruckt hat oder was man irgendwo archivieren kann, hat nach wie vor hohen Wert. Schließlich bin ich Archäologin. Man hat eben auch aus irgendwie palmyronähnlichem alte Fotos oder Zeichnungen, die auch ihren Wert haben. Von denen man nicht ganz dieselbe, aber eben wichtige Informationen bekommt, die nutzen wir zum Beispiel auch bei unseren Grabungen, da nutzen wir eben die Archive für solche Fragen.
Wie das ausgehen hat 1950, als man die Thermen da in Pompeji ausgegraben hat.
Ja und vor allem ist es ja auch so, dass man ja heute eigentlich noch gar nicht weiß, worauf man morgen vielleicht schauen möchte. Also sowohl was jetzt so Aspekte betrifft als eben auch technische Methoden. Die von Ihnen erwähnte, also C14, das meint ja diese Radiokarbonmethode, die so quasi auf der Basis von der Halbwertzeit von Kohlenstoff einfach eine relativ klar Analyse ermöglicht, wie alt etwas sozusagen ist. Ich habe es schlecht erklärt.
Nein es ist völlig richtig. Nur dieser Genauigkeitswert ist nicht sonderlich groß und für klassische Archäologen relativ unbrauchbar. Da steht dann immer da +/- 200 oder 100 Jahre und dann lachen wir schon. Da sind bei uns schon Epochengrenzen überschritten. Das heißt das ist natürlich eine sehr wichtige Methode, die in vielen Archäologien angewendet wird, für die Fragen, die wir oft tatsächlich in der klassischen Archäologie haben nicht. Also solche, diese Methode spezifisch nicht.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, zumindest wenn jetzt irgendjemand irgendwo was in der Hand hält und nicht weiß, ist das jetzt Kunst oder kann das weg, also ist das relevant für eine Forschung oder nicht und man hätte die Möglichkeit, das mal schnell zu testen. Und man stellt auf einmal fest, das ist hier die Tonscherbe von Hastdunichtgesehen, nach der alle schon seit Ewigkeiten suchen, hier die Jäger des verlorenen Schatzes.
Also so einfach ist es nicht. Das kostet ja alles viel Geld. Also erst mal, wenn Sie die Tonscherben finden, dürfen Sie die nicht einfach außer Landes nehmen, das ist Punkt Nummer 1, da machen Sie sich schon strafbar. Wenn Sie sie trotzdem mitnehmen und wollen sie irgendwie testen lassen, kostet das natürlich auch Geld.
Mir geht es nicht darum, das jetzt zu entwenden. Ich hatte nur jetzt auch gerade von so einem Fall gehört, wo einfach irgendein Wissenschaftler einfach auf dem Flohmarkt – was war das? - Bernstein, wo jetzt gerade dieser Dinosaurierschwanz mit Federn gefunden wurde. Wo halt jemand das einfach so, ja hier Bernstein mit einer Feder drin, aber überhaupt nicht geschnallt hat, dass es sich hierbei gar nicht um eine Pflanze handelte. Also sozusagen überhaupt erst mal herausfinden, dass irgendwas auch archäologisch relevant sein kann, kann an der Stelle helfen. Aber das ist ja jetzt auch nur ein Nebenkriegsschauplatz. Also ich finde das schonmal sehr interessant, die Feststellung Archäologie ist halt einfach ein Wissenschaftszweig, der enorm davon profitiert, von den technischen Fortschritten der letzten Jahre und im Prinzip hat es ja das Potenzial dort eigentlich auch extrem angereichert. Ich muss zugeben, ich weiß noch so als Jugendlicher, man schaut sich ja mal so alles an und da habe ich immer, Archäologie ja mein Gott, wie lange kann es das schon noch geben, irgendwann ist ja wahrscheinlich alles abgeschabt, da wird man ja schnell arbeitslos.
Das ist glaube keine besonders sinnvolle Sicht auf die Sache.
Nein wir, sage ich mal im besten Falle, solange uns jemand finanziert, werden sicher nicht arbeitslos. Also erstens gibt es unglaublich viel Material, was noch nicht publiziert ist, was man bearbeiten könnte, was in den Museenmagazinen und sonst wo liegt in allen Ländern gleichermaßen. Das ist das eine und das andere ist eben, dass man, quasi wenn Sie bauen in vielen Deutschlands, gehen Sie mal nach Köln oder nach Mainz, da liegt überall Geschichte. Das heißt es wird immer zumindest Notgrabungen geben, aber auch systematische Grabungen, ich sehe kein Ende ab für die Archäologie, sagen wir mal so. Und wenn man breit genug ist und eben seinen geografischen und chronologischen Blickwinkel ausweitet dann erst recht nicht. Und das passiert im Moment gerade in Berlin sehr massiv mit der Archäologie.
Da ist ja dann immer die Frage, wie vertritt man so sein eigenes Feld in der Öffentlichkeit und womit argumentiert man sozusagen die Finanzierungsbedarfe. Ist ja nicht so, dass den anderen Disziplinen nicht auch eine Menge einfallen würde, warum es jetzt ausgerechnet sie treffen muss. Da sage ich doch mal ganz kess. Was für Antworten hat denn die Archäologie so für Wissenschaft und Gesellschaft geliefert in den letzten … den Zeitraum dürfen Sie sich jetzt aussuchen? Also vielleicht einfach nur mal so ein paar Beispiele, wo Erkenntnisse aus der Archäologie jetzt auch eine extrem hohe Relevanz haben über so einen reinen Erkenntnisgewinn hinaus. Also wo sich sagen wir mal auch grundlegende Dinge dadurch geändert haben oder Sichtweisen geändert haben, wo die Art und Weise, wie man mit Wissenschaft oder über mit der Gesellschaft an sich voranschreitet, wo das einen Einfluss hatte?
Das ist jetzt eine Herausforderung die Frage. Also ich sage mal, ein unmittelbares Erkenntnisinteresse aus vielen Wissenschaft für heute halte ich für schwierig. Aber es gibt zahlreiche Themen, die Sie in der Antike untersuchen und studieren können und versuchen, Mechanismen zu analysieren, vielleicht auch Erklärungen zu finden, soweit uns das möglich ist, mit dem Abstand den wir haben mit diesen Kulturen. Themen wie Migration ganz aktuell, sind Themen, die in der Antike, wir haben das als Völkerwanderung in der Schule kennengelernt. Themen, die in der Antike eben hoch virulent waren und zu umfassenden Umwälzungen geführt haben, war jetzt zum Beispiel Thema in der Ringvorlesung dieses Exzellenzcluster Topoi. Wo man eben verschiedene Migrationen in den Blick genommen hat. Dass man dafür Lösungen für heute hat, sehe ich nicht, aber es schafft den Blickwinkel für viele Probleme und Fragestellungen und natürlich auch dafür, dass es das tatsächlich immer gegeben hat unter ganz unterschiedlichen Konstellationen und Gründen. Das wäre so ein Thema, Migration.
Kulturvergleich oder ich sage mal Kulturkontakte ist ein Thema, was wir sehr stark untersuchen in der Archäologie, eben Basis von Artefakten, aber auch literarischen Quellen. Dass wir jetzt Antworten haben, wie man konkret Probleme in verschiedenen Kiezen lösen kann, das kann ich nicht sagen, aber man sieht, dass in vielen Gesellschaften, etwa im Römischen Reich, wie man versucht hat, in den zahlreichen Provinzen, die die Römer hatte, kreativ damit umzugehen und ach sehr smart damit umzugehen. Dadurch hat das römische Reich sicher lange bestanden, dass man sehr viele lokale Eigenheiten belassen hat. Und eben auf bestimmten Ebenen sage ich mal Kontrolle eingeführt hat, römische Kontrolle, römische Werte, wenn Sie so wollen, oder Normen, römische Kultur, aber eben doch quasi nicht 1:1 was übergestülpt hat, sondern wirklich kreativ verhandelt hat zwischen lokalen und dann den neuen römischen Einflüssen. Verwaltung war zum Beispiel römisch, man hat sich mit den lokalen Eliten zum Beispiel gewissermaßen ins Benehmen versetzt, die dann durchaus auch die Römer unterstützt haben.
Aber zum Beispiel vielfältig Religion, ein ganz großes Thema heute. Man hat die lokalen Religionen einfach völlig weiter existieren lassen, solange die nicht in irgendeinen Konflikt mit der römischen Regierung kamen, war es kein Problem. Da konnte man tolerant sein. Solche Phänomene kann man untersuchen und sehen, wie so etwas durchaus erfolgreich verlaufen kann. Dass das ein 1:1 Rezept für die Anwendung in einer komplexen Gesellschaft wie heute ist, das sehe ich nicht. Das wäre auch …
Na gut 1:1 so weit will ich ja jetzt gar nicht gehen. Und vielleicht muss ja auch Archäologie nicht unbedingt immer nur in der Antike stattfinden. Das ist natürlich jetzt Ihr Gebiet so, aber die Frage ist, wann fängt es denn an? Blicken wir nicht mittlerweile auch schon auf sehr viel kürzere Zeiträume zurück mit archäologischen Grabungen? 150 Jahre, die ja dann sozusagen noch viel relevanter sind. Und was mir auch noch einfallen würde in dem Zusammenhang, schafft es nicht in gewisser Hinsicht auch interessanten Erkenntnisgewinn für so eine kulturelle Identität? Also Migration haben Sie ja schon angesprochen, also wie sehr gehören wir überhaupt zusammen oder auch nicht? Wie haben sich sozusagen auch unsere Städte, Siedlungen, unser Leben, landwirtschaftliches Wissen etc. entwickelt. Das sind doch alles auch wichtige Grundlagen, auch für eine heutige Einschätzung von Trends und zukünftigen Entwicklungen, wenn man schon mal sieht, was früher geklappt oder nicht geklappt hat.
Ja ich meine wunderbar, wenn Sie gerade die Stadtforschung ansprechen, das ist nun eins meiner Spezialgebiete. Da könnten Sie sich zum Beispiel fragen, wie sind Städte organisiert? Gibt es so eine Art städtische Grundausstattung, die allen zugute kommt. Etwas bei den Römern kann man sagen, ja es gibt ein öffentliches Wasserleitungssystem mit Fließbrunnen, die allen zugute kommen. Die, wir wissen es jetzt am besten, in Pompeji ist die am besten erforschte Stadt, die allen zugute kam. Und auch ein öffentliches Badesystem etwa oder Straßenpflasterung, Gehwege und ähnliches. Also es gibt eine gewisse öffentliche Infrastruktur, die man für alle bereitgestellt hat. Eine andere Interessante Frage ist zum Beispiel, gibt es so eine Art Differenzierung in den Stadtvierteln nach arm und reich. Was ja durchaus also in Berlin eine interessante Fragestellung ist.
Nicht nur in Berlin.
Jaja, aber gut, wir sind gerade hier. Man könnte also da zahlreiche Beispiel dafür finden, dass es die gibt. Das hat es in der antiken Stadt nicht gegeben. Man sieht genau, dass zum Beispiel in einer Stadt wie Pompeji oder Delos, wo ich geforscht habe, dass eben große und kleine Häuser, bis hin zu einfachsten Wohnungen, wenn Sie so wollen, unmittelbar nebeneinander existierten. Also ein ganz anderes Modell von sozialer Dichte, wenn Sie so wollen. Und es muss erfolgreich funktioniert haben. Also es gibt eben verschiedene Modelle des Zusammenlebens im urbanen Raum.
Genau, auf Ihren Schwerpunkt wollte ich jetzt auch nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher kommen, weil ich glaube, da steckt auch noch eine ganze Menge drin, was auch solche Fragen beantwortet. Zunächst einmal wollte ich aber nochmal aufgreifen, Sie hatten es ja schon erwähnt, diesen Exzellenzcluster Topoi, was genau ist das? Warum heißt der so und worum kümmert der sich und was haben Sie damit zu tun?
Okay, also ich bin jetzt nicht die ganz große Expertin, weil ich relativ spät erst dazugestoßen bin, vielmehr zustoßen durfte. Es geht auf die erste Exzellenzinitiative zurück, im Jahr 2007 wurde dieser Cluster oder dieses Cluster, wie man will, da sind wir uns nicht ganz einig, gegründet. Topoi, Raum und Wissen oder Space and Knowledge und behandelt eben diese beiden Aspekte und ist ich sage mal sensationell für die Berliner Landschaft. Denn von Anfang an war es nicht ein Exzellenzcluster nur für eine Universität, sondern tatsächlich ein berlinweites Exzellenzcluster, was a) verschiedene Universitäten kombiniert, also FU und HU, aber die TU ist auch dabei oft. Und dann vor allen Dingen auch die außeruniversitären Institutionen, die Antike im weitesten Sinne behandeln. Die Museen sind dabei. Ganz prominent natürlich das deutsche archäologische Institut und die Berlin-Brandenburgische Akademie der Wissenschaften und das Max-Planck-Institut, Wissenschaftsgeschichte.
Und damit haben Sie sechs große Institutionen, die da zusammenarbeiten mit wirklich zahlreichen Wissenschaftlern aus unterschiedlichen Disziplinen, die eben in vier großen thematisch gruppierten Areas, ist jetzt in Topoi2, zahlreiche Themen behandeln zum Thema Raum und Wissen im weitesten Sinne. Und es ist eine Form von Interdisziplinarität und Interinstitutionalität, die wirklich singulär sicherlich in Deutschland, ich glaube fast in der ganzen Welt, ist. Also in Amerika, wo ich lange war, hat es so was überhaupt nicht gegeben, so zu forschen. Und ist jetzt in der zweiten Runde. War also auch im zweiten Anlauf erfolgreich. Das Thema ist das gleiche geblieben, Topoi Raum und Wissen mit neuen Fragestellungen und neuen Projekten. Und ich bin seit ich in Berlin bin, das ist seit Juli 2013, relativ schnell dann mit zwei Projekten durfte ich da also einsteigen in zwei verschiedenen Gruppen, wo ich dann auch forsche jetzt.
Das heißt auch diese spezielle Förderung der Universitäten in diesen Exzellenzprojekten geht auch an der Archäologie nicht vorbei?
Oh nein überhaupt nicht. Die Archäologie war da, wenn ich das so sagen darf, also die Vorgängerin auf meiner Stelle, Friederike Fless, die jetzt die Präsidentin des deutschen archäologischen Instituts ist, die war sehr federführend dabei, Topoi 1 wirklich zu initiieren, das kann man sagen. Und hat eben sehr weit sich das unglaubliche Potenzial auch in der Berliner akademischen Landschaft erkannt und auch die Leute mit motiviert, da mitzumachen. Und sie war eben auch lange Sprecherin dieses Exzellenzclusters, bis sie dann eben ans deutsche archäologische Institut gewechselt ist. Und die Archäologien sind sehr prominent vertreten, das darf man auch so sagen.
Haben diese Exzellenzcluster dann auch den gewünschten Effekt? Dass man sozusagen, ich meine es geht ja im Prinzip darum, Spitzenforschung zu unterstützen durch eine besondere Förderung.
Unbedingt.
Hat das so einen Trickle down Effekt, wie das ursprünglich vielleicht mal gedacht war?
Also das bin ich fest von überzeugt. Ganz sicherlich, also Topoi hat die Berliner Wissenschaftslandschaft massiv verändert, in unserer Disziplin in jedem Fall. Und ist einfach wirklich auch international bekannt. Also einen internationalen Brand. Und hat ich glaube ganz neue Perspektiven in der Forschung, auch der Zusammenarbeit, neue Themen entwickelt. Also kann man nur bejahen.
Ja ich denke es ist schon ein Brand. Und man versucht eben auf allen Ebenen, also bei fortgeschritteneren Wissenschaftlern sehr viel eben auch Nachwuchsförderung ist dabei. Und ich bin jetzt im Moment auch noch Sprecherin einer Graduate School, die eben aus diesem Cluster erwachsen ist, aber jetzt eben selbständig ist. Diese Berlin Graduate School of Ancient Studies und ich sehe eben die jungen Leute, die in diesen Programmen forschen und promovieren und die Möglichkeiten sind unglaublich. Aber auch die Professionalität, die die dadurch gewinnen, ist unglaublich. Das muss ich sagen. Also die operieren da wirklich sehr häufig schon auf internationaler Ebene, das ist eine ganz neue Entwicklung.
Einen Brand?
Liegt das jetzt nur daran, dass es gut gefunded ist?
Beides. Also ich würde sagen, das Funding, natürlich manchen wir uns nichts, Geld spielt immer eine wichtige Rolle und ist ein Anreiz und ermöglicht mir zum Beispiel meine ganzen Grabungen und Forschungen. Aber mindestens genauso wichtig, wenn nicht auf lange Sicht denke ich wichtiger, ist der enorme intellektuelle Anreiz. Das ist eben was das anstößt an Inspiration und überhaupt, dass man Kenntnis von Disziplinen und Fragestellungen und Methoden hat, die man in der eigenen Disziplin so gar nicht bekommt, das finde ich eben enorm. Und das sieht man bei den jungen Wissenschaftlern. Die sitzen da nicht mehr im Kämmerlein nur und forschen drei Jahre vor sich hin, sondern die sind permanent vernetzt, die müssen permanent auch auf Workshops und Theorie- und Methodenseminare absolvieren und und und.
Die müssen das, weil es eine Anforderung ist an ein solches Exzellenzcluster so zu arbeiten oder ergibt sich das dann automatisch aus den gestiegenen Fragestellungen?
Beides. Ich meine, es gibt in dieser Graduate School natürlich ein strukturiertes Promotionsprogramm. Es gibt fünf verschiedene Programme und die schreiben einem vor, was man mehr oder weniger belegen muss. Aber daraus ergibt sich eben auch die Beratung, was es gibt, wo man hingehen soll, was man machen kann und so weiter. Und diejenigen, die da sehr engagiert und aktiv sind, die finden das alles von alleine mittlerweile.
Wird dann automatisch auch internationaler geforscht, als man das sonst tut?
Oh ja in jedem Fall. Also wir haben jetzt gerade für diese Graduate School, darauf sind wir auch sehr stolz, drei neue Abkommen mit amerikanischen Universitäten, Harvard, Princeton und Michigan, abgeschlossen, wo unsere Studenten tatsächlich für ein Semester rübergehen und kostenfrei also Kurse belegen können und amerikanische Studenten auch zu uns kommen. Also wir verstehen das immer als gegenseitig, wirklich als Austausch. Und es gibt Kooperationen mit anderen Institutionen und Universitäten, in London, Paris. Demnächst noch mit Leiden, New York und so weiter. Das wird sehr stark gefördert. Und wir haben auch sehr viele internationale Studenten, die kommen.
Das heißt dieses Modell der Exzellenzcluster ist für Sie ein positiver Einfluss der Wissenschaftslandschaft?
Hoch erfolgreich. Also das ist für mich auch einer wirklich der wichtigen Gründe gewesen, aus Amerika, wo ich sehr glücklich war, wo ich mich sehr wohlgefühlt habe, und an einer wirklich tollen Universitäten mit einem hervorragenden Departement war, doch dann zurück zu kommen. Also die Möglichkeiten der Vernetzung und die enorme Breite und die Inspiration sind da nochmal eine ganz andere. Gerade natürlich in Berlin. Aber eben besonders auch dadurch, dass dieses Cluster etabliert wurde und dadurch die Zusammenarbeit also exorbitant gewachsen ist.
Ja Ihren Lebensweg hatten wir jetzt gar nicht so ausführlich beleuchtet. Also Sie haben schon in Deutschland studiert und sind dann wie lange in den USA gewesen?
Ich war zehn Jahre in den USA. Ich bin während meiner Zeit, das war damals noch so eine C1-Stelle wissenschaftliche Assistentin, bin ich zunächst mit einem Fellowship also von Harvard University im Centre for Hellenic Studies gewesen und hatte dann Humboldt-Fellowship an der Johns Hopkins University in Baltimore und ich gehörte zu dieser Generation, die man damals etwas uncharmant als Lost Generation bezeichnet hat, als das System umgestellt wurde von C auf W. Und diese C2 etwa diese Oberassistenzen wegfielen. Wo also gar nicht klar war, wie es tatsächlich für meine Generation weitergehen würde in der Universität und habe mich dann auf dem amerikanischen Markt beworben, auf einen Assistent Professorship. Auch direkt eine bekommen an der University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill und da bin ich dann acht Jahre geblieben, bis der Ruf nach Berlin kam.
Hatte das jetzt schon was mit dem Cluster zu tun oder war das jetzt im Prinzip nur die Professur?
Beides natürlich. Sie brauchen schon auch eine Professur.
Aber der Cluster war da schon explizit mit verbunden?
Ja der war schon in der zweiten Laufphase.
Das war sozusagen ein …
Zusätzlicher Anreiz.
Ein zusätzlicher Anreiz, der dann auch tatsächlich … ich meine das ist ja so eine der Geschichten, die jetzt im Rahmen dieser ganzen Spitzenforschungsförderung immer wieder eingebracht wurde, so mit, wir müssen halt einen Incentive haben, damit Leute jetzt eben nicht immer nur in den USA hängen bleiben, da sind Sie ja im Prinzip das beste Beispiel.
Ja würde ich sagen.
Ja, nein also mir waren selbst als ich kam noch gar nicht das ganze Potential und das ganze Ausmaß bekannt, da bin ich gewissermaßen erst reingewachsen. Aber es ist wirklich nur positiv. Also wenn, das einzige ist das Zeitbudget, es gibt einfach zu viel Angebot. Das ist unglaublich. In Berlin können Sie ja oft abends zu drei verschiedenen Vorträgen gehen. Also das ist mein einziges Bedauern, dass man zu wenig Zeit hat, wirklich alles mitzunehmen, was so ein Cluster zu bieten hat.
Also ein Beispiel.
Ist nicht langweilig genug sozusagen?
Nein überhaupt nicht. Und ich meine, ich sehe es dann eben zumindest als Chance für meine Studenten, dass ich die dann da hinschicken kann oder meine wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter, wo ich überall nicht hingehen kann, können dann wenigstens die anderen hingehen.
Ja, ich würde gern mal ein bisschen auf Ihren Schwerpunkt kommen. Also wir haben es ja schon gesagt, klassische Archäologie, sprich der Blick auf die kulturelle Entwicklung des Mittelmeerraums vor allem. Im Prinzip kann man ja auch sagen, Europa, weil das ja dann auch in andere Länder und andere Regionen Europas stark reingewirkt hat. War das … gut ich meine klassische Archäologie legt das jetzt im Prinzip erst mal fest, aber Sie haben sich ja dann auch weiter spezialisiert, zumindest zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, und gesagt, ich gucke mir jetzt mal - ja ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was die beste Bezeichnung ist - ich sage mal, Bäder an. Also Sie haben sich schon speziell konzentriert auf so diese Entwicklung der Hygienekultur in den griechischen, römischen und damit verbundenen Kulturen?
Ja das ist richtig. Ich würde sagen, grundsätzlich ist mein Interesse kulturhistorischer Natur. Und ich habe zuerst über Häuser zum Beispiel geforscht, sehr viel über kommerzielle Anlagen, auch sogenannte Sklavenmärkte, ob sie nun welche sind oder nicht. Und aber auch Taberne und Vereinshäuser und ähnliches und bin quasi über dann auch Fragen der Häuser zu diesem Thema Badekultur, wie ich es gerne nenne, gekommen. Weil es tatsächlich deutlich mehr umfasst als nur die Badeanlagen als solche für mich. Es gibt Darstellungen, also etwa Vasenbilder, vermeintlich vom Baden oder Waschen. Es gibt natürlich auch Schriftquellen, die uns das ganze Umfeld davon erläutern, und in dem Sinne möchte ich Badekultur verstanden wissen. Begonnen habe ich tatsächlich chronologisch und geografisch etwas begrenzt so vom 6. Jahrhundert vor bis zum 1. Jahrhundert vor oder nach Christus im gesamten Mittelmeerraum. Und durch meine Grabung ist das jetzt ein bisschen in die Kaiserzeit ausgedehnt, aber mein Interesse galt eher dieser Zeit, 6. vor bis 1.-2. Jahrhundert nach Christus.
Wie geht man denn da erst mal ran? ich meine, da dürfte es ja schon eine ganze Menge geben. Schaut man sich das erst mal an oder fängt man dann automatisch selber an, den Pinsel zu zücken und fährt erst mal dahin?
Ja und nein. Also ich bin ganz banal darauf gestoßen. Ich hatte in den Häusern, die ich in meiner Dissertation behandelt habe, das ist auf der Insel Delos, da sind so 100 Häuser erhalten. Ist quasi das griechische Pompeji, wenn Sie so wollen. Da hatte ich Badeanlagen entdeckt und überhaupt erstmals identifiziert, die keiner vorher identifiziert hatte und das sind so Luxussaunen, wenn Sie so wollen. Und das hat mein Interesse an dieser Badekultur befördert, weil ich mich gefragt habe, warum treten die hier eben im privaten Wohnkontext auf, wie kann ich die überhaupt interpretieren? Ist das eben Luxus oder ist das Durchschnitt? Und es gab eine große Monografie von 1962 von einem französischen Forscher, René Ginouvès, hervorragendes Buch zu dieser griechischen Badekultur, aber danach gar nichts. Und da waren die nicht drin, da war das überhabt nicht entdeckt und erkannt worden. Und dann fängt man an, systematisch zu sammeln und stellte dann relativ schnell fest, dass nach 1962 sehr viele Anlagen überhaupt erst ausgegraben und identifiziert worden sind.
Aber sich niemand damit beschäftigt hat?
Nein es gab nichts dazu zu der Zeit, also als ich damit angefangen habe. So Anfang 2000. Und dann bin ich damals gereist, als ich noch gerade in Deutschland studierte, da war das immer ein bisschen leichter, im Mittelmeer zu reisen. Aber man sammelt tatsächlich in der Literatur alles was man finden kann, erst mal ganz banal. Und dann habe ich aber relativ schnell erkannt, dass man reisen muss, um sich die Anlagen anzugucken. Habe mehrere große Reisen gemacht, 2003 und 2007 dann schon aus den USA, fast im ganzen Mittelmeer. Also Ägypten zum Beispiel, was gar nicht so leicht war, weil viel im Fayum lag, mit einer Kollegin zusammen, die mir da sehr geholfen hat. Aber eben auch Türkei und alles in Griechenland. griechische Inseln, Sizilien und so weiter. Ich habe tatsächlich fast alle der mittlerweile bekannten sogenannten griechischen öffentlichen Bäder hatte ich gesehen. Und man untersucht die dann soweit wie möglich vor Ort. Also macht Fotos oder Zeichnungen, guckt sich an wie der Befund ist. Und ich bin immer an Synthese interessiert.
Also schon sehr klar Grundlagenforschung am Material selber, aber dann an synthetischen Fragestellungen, die ich dann verfolgt habe damit. Und daraus hat sich dann das Forschungsinteresse ergeben, wenn man sieht, dass nicht arg viele wirklich gut ausgegraben und vollständig erforscht sind, ob man nicht selber mal eine tatsächlich ausgräbt und erforscht.
Also ausgräbt, also im Sinne von, sich nochmal genauer anschaut oder überhaupt erst mal entdeckt?
Nein richtig ausgräbt. Also es gibt zahlreiche Beispiele, die sind gar nicht publiziert, die können Sie aber auch gar nicht alle in Ihrem Forscherleben publizieren und irgendwann würde Ihnen das wahrscheinlich auch langweilig, weil die ja relativ standardisiert dann doch sind. Aber trotzdem war die Neugier und das Interesse da, wie ist das tatsächlich, wenn man eine eben ausgräbt und nicht nur Material hat, was vor vielen Jahren ausgegraben ist und in einem relativ entsprechend schlechten Zustand oder man hat nicht die vollständige Dokumentation oder die Funde, um so was angemessen zu beurteilen. Das sind ja alles Punkte. In Ägypten haben wir Bäder gesehen, die waren überhaupt noch nirgendwo erwähnt, durch puren Zufall irgendwo im Fayum am Rande der Wüste. Und da suchen Sie verzweifelt nach irgendwelchen Publikationen. Sie können aber auch nicht hingehen mit dem Maßband und sagen, ich nehme die jetzt mal auf. Das geht nicht so ohne Weiteres.
Ich merke übrigens gerade, dass Sie ja wirklich eine herausragend attraktive Eigenschaft des Archäologiestudiums unterschlagen haben. Andere Leute werden erst Aerobic-Trainer, um so viel reisen zu können. Das ist ja hier sozusagen auch noch gleich mit eingepreist. Aber jetzt würde mich doch mal wirklich interessieren, also es ist jetzt da Ihr Interesse geweckt worden. Jetzt stellt man fest, okay da hat jetzt gar keiner zu publiziert, das ist ja auch so eine tolle Sache so als Wissenschaftler, denke ich mir immer so, oh ein Feld, was noch komplett unbeleuchtet ist. Dann reist man, dann schaut man sich irgendwie das Ganze an. Was heißt denn das jetzt? Fährt man da sozusagen so als Touristengruppe hin, mit einer Lupe in der Hand oder zieht man das auch gleich größer auf, hat eine ganze Truppe am Start? Mit wem muss man denn da überhaupt reden, dass man sich diesen alten Städten auch intensiv nähern kann?
Also es gibt verschiedene Formen. Und bei synthetischen Arbeiten ist das nicht leicht.
Was meinen Sie denn mit synthetischer Arbeit?
Naja das ist, ich habe mir 75-80 öffentliche griechische Bäder angeguckt. Die können Sie nicht alle monografisch erfassen. Sie wollen aber trotzdem quasi schreiben, wie entwickeln sich diese Bäder, was sind deren Standards, wie groß sind die, was für Badeprogramme haben die, was für eine Technologie? Das meine ich mit Synthese. Und Sie versuchen dann, zum Beispiel ist mir dann aufgefallen und das hat sich auch bewahrheitet, dass es regional ganz klare Unterschiede zwischen Süd-Ost-Mittelmeer, also vor allen Dingen Ägypten gibt, zentral, also Griechenland, und dann im Westen Sizilien. Also solche großen …
Also Synthese aus der Erkenntnislage sozusagen ein System ableiten mit, das ist sozusagen das was ich hier strukturell sehe, die unterscheiden sich so und so.
Ja.
Oder das ist Standard und das ist Ausnahme?
Genau, Sie stellen fest, in Griechenland gibt es überhaupt schon im 5./4. Jahrhundert Bäder, in anderen Regionen geht es deutlich später los und wie entwickelt sich dann was? sind da präferierte Badeformen, was sind die Standards und Technologien und da sieht man massive Unterschiede. Das kriegen Sie aber nur raus, wenn Sie viele wirklich systematisch angeguckt haben und versuchen zum Beispiel auch zu datieren und die Bauentwicklung und so weiter nachzuvollziehen. Also wenn Sie so wollen, Standardfragestellungen, die man in irgendsoeinem Fach hat. Für viele hatte ich eine Genehmigung regelrecht eingeholt. Aber nur eine, um dort hinzugehen, gegebenenfalls zu messen und Fotos zu machen. Graben können Sie nicht einfach so. Das ist viel viel komplizierter. Sie können überall als Tourist hinreisen, sofern das politisch unproblematisch ist, aber dann dürfen Sie eigentlich nicht messen. Dann können Sie natürlich Fotos machen, aber in der Wissenschaft ist normalerweise schon korrekt üblich, dass Sie sich Genehmigungen einholen, je nachdem was vor Ort Sie machen wollen.
Da gibt es gewisse Grauzonen. Wenn Sie graben wollen, liegt die Sache nochmal ganz anders.
Bei wie vielen von diesen 80 Objekten haben Sie jetzt da Tourismus betrieben?
Als für Griechenland und Sizilien denke ich hatte für fast alle Anlagen eine richtige Genehmigung, also um sie mir nur anzugucken, nicht zu untersuchen. In Ägypten war das viel schwieriger, weil von manchen war ja die Existenz nicht bekannt, da habe ich also viele einfach nur touristisch angeguckt. Aber die habe ich auch am wenigsten…
Was war denn schwieriger? Da mit den Behörden auf einen Zweig zu kommen oder überhaupt erst mal rauszufinden, wo man hinfahren will?
Also in Ägypten war erst mal schwieriger zu identifizieren, wo die sind. Wir hatten dann, da bin ich mit einer Kollegin, Marianne Bergmann, die hatte eins ausgegraben in der Nähe, im Hafen von Alexandria Iskandriyya hatte sie eins ausgegraben. Und wir sind dann regelrecht mit einem Fahrer rumgefahren und einem Inspektor damals, insofern war das offiziell. Wir hatten also einen ägyptischen Inspektor, der uns auch sehr unterstützt hat, um dann zu identifizieren, wo die liegen. Und dann hat man hinterher die GPS-Koordinaten genommen. Wenn Sie mal wissen, wo die sind, können Sie dann in Google-Earth angucken, wo die sind. Und ich habe also mit Kollegen ein Buch publiziert mit einem Katalog all dieser Bäder, da haben wir dann die GPS-Daten auch angegeben, aber wir hatten die nicht. Wir hatten die erst mal gar nicht. Und hinterher können Sie nachvollziehen, wo Sie da waren. Da gibt es jetzt auch keine Straßenkarten, wo Sie mal eben einfach da im Delta oder im Fayum, das sind beides untouristische Regionen. Da steht nicht irgendwie …
Keine Postleitzahl sozusagen.
… hier geht es zu den Pyramiden oder zu den griechischen Bädern. Schon eine Herausforderung.
In Griechenland ist das alles schon ein bisschen organisierter?
Ja in Griechenland ist es organisierter.
Die sind das irgendwie gewohnt, dass da alle vorbeikommen.
Naja gut, da gibt es auch ganz offizielle, da geht man über das deutsche archäologische Institut als Deutscher, stellt die Anträge, die leiten das weiter. Da gibt es klare Prozesse, wie das läuft. Wie gesagt, in Ägypten auch, nur die Sachlage war einfach eine andere.
Okay, aber in Griechenland ist das dann schon so, diese Stätten haben dann alle eine griechische archäologische Stättennummer und die kann man dann angeben und sagen, ich möchte.
Ja die sind bekannt. Und dann zum Beispiel in Eleusis, das ist ein berühmtes Heiligtum der Demeter, da hat mir eben die griechische Kollegin damals sehr geholfen, das Bad war komplett wieder zugeschüttet und zwei Arbeiter sogar gegeben, die das partiell wieder freigelegt haben. Auch da war es zum Teil so, dass man zwar wusste, das hat mal jemand ausgegraben, aber wo das liegt ist nicht immer …
Ja ich meine, die überwachsen und überwuchern dann. Die Stätten sind zum Teil ausgedehnt. Sie können auch überall wo Sie hinkommen, müssten Sie im Prinzip erst putzen, Unkraut jäten, putzen. Ich habe mal über Latrinen in Delos gearbeitet, das war in dieser Hinsicht …
Zugeschüttet?
… eine Herausforderung.
Ja da hatte sich keiner für interessiert, da war viel in dieser Hinsicht zu leisten.
Ich war dummerweise immer noch nicht in Griechenland, aber es scheint ja offensichtlich so zu sein, dass man da einfach am laufenden Meter über alte Geschichte stolpert.
Ah fantastisches Land unglaublich.
Man rennt da sozusagen immer in so was rein. Ist ja auch so ein Problem. Ich kenne das immer so aus Italien, wo sie ja irgendwie schon seit längerem versuchen, da längere U-Bahn-Strecken zu bauen, aber das …
Ja Gott sei dank, die Archäologen lieben das gar nicht.
Ja die U-Bahn-Bauer ja auch nicht, weil da müssen sie immer alle zwei Meter wieder Halt machen, dann ein Jahr warten, bis alles ausgegraben ist. Ich meine, ist ja auch eine Chance. In Berlin hat sich ja hier vor dem Roten Rathaus durch die Baustelle ja dann tatsächlich auch noch ein Fund ergeben, mit dem auch keiner gerechnet hat. Dass dann hier noch eigentlich verschollene Kunst, von der man dachte, sie sei verschollen, von den Nazis weggebracht, geraubt, zerstört, was auch immer, dann wieder aufgefunden wurde und das halt direkt vor dem Rathaus.
Ja sehen Sie mal, wie wichtig das ist.
Genau, das stellt hier gar keiner in Frage. Aber bleiben wir jetzt nochmal an den Bädern, weil das finde ich jetzt wirklich interessant. Ich meine, Griechenland und Rom ganz klar sind ja jetzt nicht nur, wie man so schön sagt, die Urstätte der Demokratie und der gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung, es sind ja auch technologische Entwicklungsherde gewesen damals. Und ich habe so den Eindruck, das hat sich eigentlich kaum irgendwo so extrem niedergeschlagen, wie genau in der Architektur und dort konkret auch in der Art und Weise, wie man mit Wasser und mit Wärme umgegangen ist.
Ja das kann man ganz sicherlich sagen. Also ich würde sagen, es gibt drei zentrale Bereiche, wo die Bäder also unglaubliche Innovation erkennen lassen, wenn nicht sogar befördert haben. Das ist immer dieses Henne-Ei-Spiel. Aber die drei Bereiche sind einmal natürlich tatsächlich Wassermanagement, Wasserversorgung und aber auch -entsorgung. Das zweite ist die Heiztechnik. Und das dritte ist der Gewölbebau, was vielen nicht klar ist. Also in Morgantina in Sizilien, wo eine der Grabungen ist, die die Amerikaner da haben und ich durfte da als Codirektorin mitmachen, da hat man gleich zwei griechische Bäder, so um 250 vor Christus errichtet, ausgegraben. Und bei dem einen, dem sogenannten Nordbad, hat man eine ganz revolutionäre Gewölbetechnik aus ineinander gesteckten Tonrohren gefunden. Das ist das erste Mal und einzigartig.
Und nicht weit entfernt, in Caulonia, das ist in Süditalien, da unten im Stiefel, da hat man ungefähr aus der zweiten Hälfte des dritten Jahrhunderts wiederum auch eine Badeanlage mit einem gleichermaßen sensationellen System aus Bögen, die sind aus Stein und aus Terrakotta gemacht. Und ich könnte Ihnen jetzt zahlreiche oder mehrere Beispiele noch nennen, wo klar ist, dass die Gewölbetechnik in diesen Bädern hat man experimentiert. Und man findet dann in den Stabianer-Thermen in Pompeji, wo wir auch graben im Rahmen unseres Topoi-Projektes zum Beispiel schon dieses sogenannte Gussgewölbe, Opus Caementitium, was eine Revolution der Römer ist. Also man sieht in all diesen verschiedenen Badeanlagen, experimentiert man mit unterschiedlichen Technologien, bis man dann diese perfekten Zementgewölbe hat. Der andere Bereich, die Wasserversorgung, ist ganz klar, also am liebsten hätten ja natürlich alle Fließwasserversorgung, und da ist das Projekt in Pompeji ganz besonders wichtig, in diesen berühmten Stabianer-Thermen, die wirklich jeder Tourist kennt, der nach Pompeji kommt, sieht die.
Da haben wir eben die Chronologie komplett revidieren können, die da bislang etabliert war. Und ein wesentliches Interesse ist, wie die Technologie sich entwickelte. Und die hatten am Anfang einen Tiefbrunnen mit einem relativ aufwendigen Wasserhebesystem. Und dann gibt es aber wirklich einen Quantensprung in der Entwicklung in dem Moment, wo die Badeanlage an die neue städtische Wasserleitung angeschlossen wird. Und das kann man ziemlich klar in der relativen und absoluten Chronologie jetzt doch sehen. Und dann sieht man eben, wie sich dann gewissermaßen das Konzept und die Möglichkeiten von Bädern wirklich signifikant ändern in dieser Anlage. Und wie die das also gewährleisten, auch das Wasser zu verteilen physisch in so einer Badeanlage, in die Badeanlage reinpumpen und wie sie es physisch verteilen. Also Wasser war ganz zentral. Und der Vorläufer ist diese Anlage in Morgantina, wo das mit der Wasserversorgung noch ziemlich schwierig ist. Da gibt es halt nur ein Reservoire für Regenwasser.
Und mein Verdacht ist schon, dass diese Anlagen nicht ganzjährig jederzeit verlässlich funktionierten. Das wissen wir aus Ägypten sehr gut, da gibt es Papyri, die uns das bestätigen. Da wurden die Bäder eben, die profitable Investments von Privatleuten waren, die wurden vermietet oder verpachtet und da beschwert sich der Pächter, ah ich kann dir diesen Monat oder diese Woche die Pacht nicht zahlen, weil der Brunnen kein Wasser mehr hatte oder ich musste einen neuen Brunnen graben und deswegen habe ich dann Verlust von Tageseinnahmen. Also Wasserversorgung ist ein Problem. Und Heiztechnik ist das andere, was faszinierend ist. Wir kennen alle diese typischen Hypokausten bei den Römern, die Fußbodenheizung. Und wir können aber jetzt genau nachvollziehen, wie die Entwicklung davon ist. Das fing in diesen griechischen Bädern an. Das hat man auch lange nicht gewusst oder ignoriert. Man hat immer gedacht, ach die Römer das sind die großen Ingenieure, die haben das alles erfunden. Wir sehen es aber 250 vor Christus den sogenannten sizilisch-süditalienisch-griechisch beeinflussen Bereich.
Also es ist quasi präfiguriert dort und sehen, wie die auch da wieder experimentieren mit Heizkanälen unter so Warmwassertauchbecken und dann fängt man sukzessive an, den ganzen Boden damit zu beheizen. Und das haben wir erstmals in der Badeanlage, die andere die wir in Pompeji quasi wiederentdeckt haben und gründlich untersuchen, sind die republikanischen Thermen. Die kennt tatsächlich kaum ein Tourist, weil die gar nicht öffentlich zugänglich sind. Aber man kann wirklich Schritt für Schritt an den Anlagen, die wir haben, nachvollziehen, wie sich da die Technologie und der Standard wandelte. Und das hat also dann enorme Auswirkungen auf die Badekultur.
Badekultur heißt ja im Prinzip, das klingt jetzt so ein bisschen so als Luxusding, aber eigentlich reden wir ja nicht von Luxus, also vielleicht auch, aber wir reden vor allem auch von einer Etablierung einer Hygiene, eines Hygienesystems für die Städte und damit auch die Möglichkeit, überhaupt eine Verdichtung dieser Städte durchzuziehen. Sehe ich das richtig?
Das weiß man fürs 19. Jahrhundert. Und das finde ich auch sehr faszinierend. Im 19. Jahrhundert kann man diese Zusammenhänge, die sind auch sehr gut untersucht, da gibt es zahlreiche Bücher. Und da mich eben Kulturvergleiche sehr interessieren, habe ich dazu viel auch gelesen. Im 19. Jahrhundert, wo die Industrialisierung, die Urbanisierung kommt, das Problem der Seuchen, wo man eben anfängt, systematisch Abwassersysteme zu haben. Und dann eben auch regelrechte Reinlichkeitsprogramme fährt. Mit Duschbädern in irgendwelchen Fabriken oder Duschbädern, wo man versucht die Frauen hinzuziehen, damit sie gewissermaßen ihre Kinder zur Reinlichkeit erziehen. Also wo man Erziehungsprogramme für den reinlichen Bürger, wie man das auch genannt hat, fährt. Da kennt man die Zusammenhänge. In der Antike ist ein Grundsatzproblem, dass wir nicht genau wissen, wie die Dichte dieser Bäder waren. Also wir können nicht 100% quantifizieren. Ich sage es mal …
Also wie viele Leute das genutzt haben?
Wir wissen nicht mal, wie viele Bäder eine Stadt hatte. Pompeji haben wir ganz gut im Griff, da können wir es sehen. Es gibt mehr und mehr andere Städte, zum Beispiel Eretria auf Euboea, wo die Schweizer graben. In Ägypten gibt es zahlreiche so kleine Dörfer, regelrecht Dörfer im Fayum, die bis zu 3-4 große Badeanlagen haben. Also ich habe es mal zusammengestellt in einem Artikel, weil mich eben genau interessierte, wie dicht ist das Netz öffentlicher Bäder ganz banal. Wie viele hatten potentiell in welchem Radius Zugang dazu? Quantifizieren wie viele das nutzen konnten ist schwierig, wir wissen oft nicht, was die Einwohnerzahl der Städte ist. Dann wissen wir nicht, ob die Leute jeden Tag gingen. Wie lang diese Bäder auf waren und so weiter. Ihnen fehlen also viele Parameter, aber trotzdem. Also wenn ich in einem Dorf im Fayum vier Bäder habe, dann kann ich relativ gut sagen, dass doch wahrscheinlich große Teile der Bevölkerung Zugang hatten. In Athen kennen wir nicht so viele Bäder bislang.
Aber da sind die gewissermaßen wie so ein Kranz außen an den Stadttoren verteilt. Und in Pompeji können wir ganz gut sehen und das ist auch Ziel unseres Projektes, wir untersuchen auch das Cityscaping gewissermaßen, die chronologische Entwicklung. Im 2. Jahrhundert haben wir zwei Anlagen und dann werden das sukzessive mehr. Und auch an unterschiedlichen Standpunkten und dann sind die auch differenziert, in dem was die bieten, als Badeprogramm und auch als Ausstattung. Da gibt es dann schon so eine Bandbreite, Luxusbäder und die einfacheren Bäder.
Und was ist jetzt so Ihre Vermutung, wie diese ganzen Bauten in ihrer Funktion für die Gesellschaft einzuordnen sind? Also was lässt sich aus diesen archäologischen Erkenntnissen da ableiten?
Also ich denke schon, die Bäder waren in den … das wissen wir dann besser aus den römischen vielleicht als aus den griechischen Städten … wichtige zentrale Orte, wo man relativ regelmäßig hinging. Wahrscheinlich doch große Teile der Bevölkerung. Und die hatten immer eine Art reinigenden Effekt. Man hat sich gestritten, bis hin zu Papers in Nature, wie hygienisch diese Anlagen waren. Das ist natürlich zum Teil einfach eine moderne Fragevorstellung. Denn Hygiene ist ja kulturspezifisch definiert und die hatten in der Antike keine Ahnung, wie Krankheiten übertragen wurden zum Beispiel. Aber trotzdem allein der Faktor, dass man da mehr oder weniger jeden Tag oder regelmäßig hinging und seinen Körper mit Wasser reinigte, ist signifikant. Und das war eben auch geselliges Beisammensein. Sie konnten da längere Zeit verweilen, weil das Klima entsprechend war, weil es eben eine Bandbreite an Badeformen in diesen gerade römischen Bädern gab.
Und wir wissen aus der Literatur durchaus, dass man sich da eben aufhielt und es waren so gesellige Treffpunkte, wenn Sie so wollen.
Aber vielleicht auch erst in zweiter Stufe. Dass man sozusagen die Bäder erst mal gebaut hat, um einfach erst mal so zu automatisieren. Also sozusagen weil ist ja jetzt nicht jedem einzelnen so ohne weiteres möglich, dieselbe Qualität gerade jetzt mit Fußbodenheizung und so weiter, dass das Wasser überhaupt da ist, fließend ist, an einer Stelle ist. Dann ist das sozusagen so ein Abfallprodukt, dass man sagt, okay dann bauen wir doch jetzt mal so ein Bad. Und dann stellen sie fest, okay jetzt sind wir ja alle hier und jetzt wirkt es auch als Kommunikationsort, weil wir eben da alle sind. Aber es ist nicht primär als solches gebaut worden?
Das wissen wir nicht.
Also ich sage mal, die frühesten Badeanlagen, die wir haben, so ab 450 vor Christus, vielleicht zweite Hälfte 5. Jahrhundert vor Christus in Athen, und im 4. Jahrhundert die, die haben Rundräume und dann sind quasi außen an den Wänden so Sitzbadewannen. Eine dicht neben der anderen. Bis zu 25 Stück in so einer Tholos, wie wir die nennen, so ein Rundraum. Da sitzen Sie direkt neben Ihrem Nachbarn, ob Sie wollen oder nicht, gibt es da eine Art von Kommunikation. Die Dinger waren dunkel und wahrscheinlich voller Dampf. Aber trotzdem es ist schon … und die Literatur suggeriert uns zum Beispiel, dass junge Männer, die eher im Gymnasium trainieren sollten, da lieber nicht hingehen sollten, weil die so auch ein bisschen anrüchige Reputation hatten. Also man wird sie jetzt nicht primär gebaut haben, um da sich zu treffen und zu unterhalten, das ist schon richtig. Das Baden hat immer eine zentrale Rolle gespielt. Aber ich nehme an, dass von Vornherein, man konnte sich ja auch zu Hause irgendwie reinigen, vielleicht primitiver und einfacher. Es gibt Städte wie Olynth in Nordgriechenland, da haben doch ein Viertel aller Häuser kleine private Badezimmer.
Schwer zu sagen oder?
Also das gab es schon parallel auch als Möglichkeit und Option. Von daher ist das öffentliche Bad immer notgedrungen sozial geselliger Treffpunkt gewesen. Das wird man nicht ausschließen.
Spielt da auch Prostitution oder so etwas eine Rolle?
Ja das wird man immer gefragt. Also ja hat sicherlich eine Rolle gespielt. Also auch die Frage, ob die nackt gebadet haben ja oder nein, ewig umstritten, nie vollständig zu lösen. Das hat es sicherlich gegeben, das legen die Schriftquellen nahe und am besten reinigen Sie sich nunmal, wenn Sie nackt sind. Und dann wird es auch Prostitution gegeben haben. Das war eben bisschen die anrüchige Reputation der athenischen Bäder etwa und bis hin zum römischen. Aber nicht als systematisches also es gab sehr unterschiedliche Bäder. Sie sagten das eben nochmal, die sind dann dunkel und schlecht. In Rom kennen wir das am besten von den Schriftstellern wie Martial, der ganz klar unterschiedliche Kategorien von Bädern, da gab es die Hip und Inbäder, die so schicken Bäder, die sicherlich auch deutlich teurer im Eintritt waren. Mit luxuriösesten Materialien ausgestattet und da traf man sich halt, wenn man zu bestimmten Gruppen und Kreisen gehörte.
Und es gab die ganz banalen Nachbarschaftsbäder, wenn Sie so wollen. Die dunklen, die dann als hölzerne Bäder beschrieben werden. Das ist jetzt nur ein Bild oder Symbol, aber es gab eine ganz große Bandbreite an Qualitätsstufen, die sicherlich auch unterschiedliche Eintrittsgelder, unterschiedliche Programme da boten.
Jetzt haben Sie sich Orte angeschaut in Griechenland, in Ägypten, Rom, darüber hinaus auch?
Ja, also in der Türkei. In der Türkei ist leider nicht viel erhalten, zumindest von diesen griechischen Badeanlagen, die mich damals Interessierten primär, die sind da wesentlich überbaut in späterer Zeit. Also auf verschiedenen Inseln. Fast überall da, einzig war ich nicht in Frankreich, aber da kennt man nur ein im Moment aus dieser Zeit in Marseille. Ansonsten in Tunesien hatte ich mir früher mal Anlagen angeguckt, bin ich eigentlich in fast allen Ländern gewesen. Zypern war ich zum Beispiel auch. Also ich bin gewissermaßen den Badeanlagen nachgefahren, wenn Sie so wollen.
Was lässt sich denn da so an technologischer Entwicklung noch machen? Also wir hatten es ja schon anfangs kurz angedeutet, dass überhaupt erst mal die Wasserversorgung an sich ja auch gelöst werden musste. Jetzt fallen uns allen gleich wieder die lustigen Monty Python Szenen ein, die Aquädukte und so.
Was haben uns die Römer gebracht? Ja also das kann man ganz gut sehen. Jetzt gerade in Athen hat eine Kollegin, die Frau Stroszeck, die da den Karameikos leitet, die hat diese Anlage, das ist die früheste bekannte, die wir im Moment haben, deswegen ist die so wichtig, völlig neu untersucht und sensationelle Entdeckungen gemacht. Ein ganzes Zisternensystem unterirdisch. Große Zisternen tatsächlich, Zisternen-Brunnensysteme.
Also Wasserspeicher.
Genau, das ist ein stiefmütterlich behandeltes Thema. Man hat also auch diese Anlagen ausgegraben, erkannt, okay Baderaum und dann hat man aufgehört. Also die wenigsten sind wirklich vollständig untersucht. Ich habe auch im Rahmen dieses Topoi-Exzellenzclusters mal versucht zusammenzustellen, was wir über die Wasserversorgung wissen und es ist relativ wenig. Also am Anfang hat man tatsächlich die Brunnen- und Zisternenanlagen, dann kommen eben Tiefbrunnen wie in den Stabianer-Thermen, wo sie Wasserhebewerke haben, die also regelrechte mechanische Wasserhebewerke schon ziemlich sophisticated. Und dann der nächste Punkt sind die Wasserleitungen. Das sind die Schritte, die man in der Wasserversorgung ganz gut sehen kann. Und im Römischen Reich war ein Grund, dass die aufhörten, okay die Christen hatten meinetwegen Probleme mit der Badekultur und ein viel größere Grund war gewöhnlich, wenn die Wasserversorgung abgeschnitten wurde, dann haben die Bäder eklatant gelitten. Oder mussten aufgegeben werden. Also man sieht da die drei Schritte ganz gut. Und in der Heiztechnik hat es von Anfang an in diesen Bädern warmes Wasser gegeben. Das muss man immer wieder betonen.
Das heißt man brauchte am Anfang große Öfen, auf denen man Kessel mit warmem Wasser erhitzt hat, das war der erste Punkt für 2-3 Jahrhunderte. Und dann kommt auf einmal dieser Schritt, dass man sagt, oh ich kann nicht nur das Wasser beheizen, sondern auch die Badeformen, also unter der Wanne mal so einen Kanal machen und dann ist von unten haben sie so eine Wannenbodenheizung, wenn Sie so wollen. Und der nächste Schritt war dann, tatsächlich den ganzen Raum, das ist ein enormer Schritt. Dann müssen Sie den ganzen Raum unterkellern, wenn Sie so wollen, und in den republikanischen Thermen hat man da so Kanalheizungen gemacht. Die hatten noch nicht diese typischen Pfeiler, die viele kennen. Es war der nächste Schritt. Man hat erst diese Kanalheizung, die war ein bisschen suboptimal, aber immerhin und dann hat man die Pfeiler gehabt. Und dann hat man eben auch Wandheizung eingeführt. Da kennen wir schon die ersten Formen in den ägyptischen Bädern.
Also die Pfeiler, das sind schon die erwähnten Hypokausten?
Hypokausten genau.
So einen Zwischenboden. So einen doppelten Boden mit kleinen Pfeilern, die was weiß ich so einen halben Meter hoch sind?
Nein ein Meter schon. Ja das variiert.
Nein nein. Also das ist unsere heutige Fußbodenheizung, die ist zum Teil ähnlich. In der Antike hat man immer nur heiße Luft durch geschickt. Also die haben irgendwo ein sogenanntes Präfonium, also Heizkammer, da machen Sie ein riesiges Feuer und die heiße Luft zieht und zirkuliert zwischen diesen Hypokausten Pfeilern, in den Fußböden und dann eben auch in den Wänden. Man hat dann eben auch doppelte Wände, sie haben doppelte Böden, doppelte Wände, da zirkuliert die heiße Luft. Und dann beheizt man eben zusätzlich noch das Wasser und führt eben heißes Wasser in die Wannen ein. Das sind dann die Punkte. Und das hat man tatsächlich recht schrittweise gemacht. es gibt viele Experimente, die parallel laufen. Aber ich sage mal so, im ersten Jahrhundert nach Christus hatte man es dann voll begriffen und sind eigentlich alle Faktoren ganz gut ausgereift. Dann hat man zum Beispiel auch noch Fensterglas entdeckt. Das war ein wirklich nächster wichtiger Schritt und systematisch eingesetzt. Vorher waren die, wenn Sie heute noch in Pompeji sind, die Bäder sind ziemlich dunkel. Wenn es dann mal grau und schlechtes Wetter draußen ist und Sie gehen in die berühmten Forumsthermen sehen Sie fast nichts.
Und da drunter ist dann warmes Wasser?
Und man hat dann eben im ersten Jahrhundert, sieht man auch in Pompeji, erstmals eben große Fenster einbauen können, weil man Fensterglas verwenden konnte.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Baden gesprochen, betrifft Ihre Forschung auch sozusagen die Toiletten?
Jaja.
Das finde ich in gewisser Hinsicht noch spannender. Weil ich meine, beim Baden konnte man sich jetzt lange streiten über die Notwendigkeit sozusagen und welchen Vorteil das jetzt hat, wenn alle gemeinsam baden. Aber so ein Entsorgungssystem ist natürlich eine ganz andere Nummer für eine Stadt.
Also darauf bin ich auch wieder durch meine Forschungen in Delos gekommen. Wie gesagt da gibt es diese ungefähr 90-100 Häuser und man hatte das schon lange erkannt und ich habe das gewissermaßen, mich interessierte die Standardausstattung dieser Häuser und wie sich Wohnkultur entwickelt. Also wenn Sie Veränderungen notieren, Sie können die erst ganz banal beschreiben. Also dieses Haus war erst klein und dann kommt rechts und links ein Raum dazu oder dann kriegt das so ein Hof mit Kolonnaden drin. Oder es bekommt eben ein neues Badezimmer oder es bekommt eine Latrine. Ich habe diese Faktoren und die habe ich wieder synthetisch untersucht. Also kriegt nur ein Haus das oder lassen sich Trends formulieren bei allen Häusern? Und dann ist natürlich sehr schnell aufgefallen, dass sehr viele Häuser eine Latrine haben.
Also Latrine definieren Sie jetzt als was genau?
Na eine Latrine ist ein, wie sagt man so schön, ein eigener Raum, also eine eigene Toilette. Also ein eigener Raum, manchmal nur ein Verschlag, wenn Sie so wollen, aber immerhin ein eigenes Lokal definiert, spezifisch nur, um da auf die Toilette zu gehen. Und das ist natürlich sensationell. Wir kennen die frühere Entwicklung wiederum da kennen wir Schriftquellen oder Vasenbilder oder auch archäologische Befunde, dass man eben Gefäße hatte, Nachttöpfe wenn Sie so wollen. Oder man hatte auch Senkgruben. Man hat das Material, ja die Fäkalien, auch tatsächlich benutzt als Dünger auf den Feldern. Umgenutzt wenn Sie so wollen. Da kennen wir die Entwicklung ganz gut. Und dann auf einmal auch wieder so im Hellenismus, wo es in der Badekultur da diesen Quantensprung gibt, gibt es eigene Räumlichkeiten, ja einen eigenen Raum. Und dann eben auch Installationen, das kennen viele. Sind diese berühmten Gräben, man macht also einen Graben an einer Mauer entlang und dann darüber ist ein Brett mit Löchern drin, da können Sie sich hinsetzen.
Donnerbalken.
Ja. Und das interessante in Delos ist nun aber, und das hatte man nicht wirklich kommentiert, das sind fast alles Multiseater, das sind gewissermaßen kollektive Toiletten. Wir haben in Häusern, wenn Sie die Länge der Kanäle bemessen, so machen wir das und können gucken, ungefähr wie viele Löcher passen dahin. Dann haben Sie teilweise in Häusern Toiletten mit neun Löchern. Was natürlich auch suggeriert, dass man das kollektiv irgendwie genutzt haben könnte oder genutzt hat. Ähnliches Phänomen habe ich übrigens dann wirklich tatsächlich noch in North Carolina gesehen in so einer Schule, wo Sie denken, die Amerikaner waren furchtbar prüde im 19./20. Jahrhundert. So eine Schule für Mädchen, wo das Outhouse dann einen Dreisitzer hatte, drei Löcher. Was eigentlich auch suggeriert, dass man die schon mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig nutzen konnte. Aber in jedem Fall von da ausgehend habe ich dann mal teilgenommen an einer Latrinenkonferenz in Rom 2007, da ging es natürlich wesentlich wieder um die Römischen.
Denn wir sind viel besser informiert übers Römische. Aber einzig und allein sag ich mal, weil kulturell die Entwicklung eigener Räumlichkeiten eben erst im 3./2. Jahrhundert vor Christus losgeht. In so einer Art mediterranen Koine, wenn Sie so wollen. Da kriegen wir sie im hellenistischen Osten und dann machen die Römer das eben weiter.
Koine?
Koine, also Gemeinschaft, so einer globalen mediterranen Welt, setzt sich das dann als Standard durch. Und es gibt unglaubliche Asymmetrien, wie in der Badekultur auch. Mich interessiert eben, ob das ein Standard wird, den dann alle gleichermaßen bekommen. Wir haben aber Städte wie Delos, wo jedes Kleinsthaus eine Latrine hat, und wir haben fantastische Städte wie Pergamon oder Priene, wo sie gar keine Latrinen haben. Das heißt es ist kein mediterraner Standard, sondern es sind lokale Phänomene, wo die Erklärungen nicht immer verstehen, also wir können nicht immer erklären, warum es so ist.
Aber das sind jetzt noch keine Systeme, die säbelt wiederum mit Wasser bespielt werden?
Doch. Das habe ich natürlich auch untersucht, sonst funktioniert die Latrine ja nicht.
Na weiß ja nicht. Bisher habe ich nur was von Löchern im Boden gehört.
Nein, also natürlich der Kanal ist da. In Pompeji gibt es zum Beispiel Senkgruben, da sind diese Latrinen mit Senkgruben, die man dann manuell entleeren muss. In Delos hatte man Kanäle, die von Wasser durchspült wurden und das war aber jetzt nicht Fließwasser. Das ist eine Illusion, sondern eben oft Abwasser wurde da reingeleitet, von irgendwelchen Haushalts- oder Küchentätigkeiten oder auch vom Dach das Wasser runtergeleitet. Es gibt verschiedene Mechanismen, das war suboptimal. Das war jetzt keine Spülwasser-Toilette, aber es war schon da.
Es gab zumindest ein bisschen Distribution sozusagen.
Es gab die Möglichkeit, eben mit 2-3 Eimern Wasser das in die Straße in ein öffentliches Abwassersystem hinauszureiten. Und ähnliches sehen wir bei Badeabwasser, das wird zum Beispiel bevorzugt durch solche Latrinen geleitet. Aber es kann nicht wie später mit Knopfdruck, die permanente Spülfunktion funktioniert da nicht.
Nein klar. Aber das heißt auch, dass es ein Abwassersystem gab. Also nicht nur, dass man es jetzt irgendwo wegspült, ist ja immer die Frage, wo landet es dann, dann liegt es irgendwie auf der Straße, das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so optimal.
Nein es gab das …
Wie weit ging denn das mit dem Abwassersystem?
Also in Delos gab es das Abwassersystem in der ganzen Stadt und ging natürlich raus ins Meer, muss man bedauerlicherweise sagen, ist nur eine Insel und ist klar, wo das irgendwann landete. In Pompeji gibt es zum Beispiel kein flächendeckendes Abwassersystem in der ganzen Stadt. Das hängt auch mit den geologischen Beschaffenheiten zusammen. Es gibt nur partiell Abwasser, also gerade für die großen Bäder oder auch für andere öffentliche Bauten, aber viele Häuser, ich erwähnte es eben schon, haben Senkgruben, wo die Flüssigkeit versickert, der Urin versickert und die Fäkalien müssen manuell rausgeholt werden. Herculaneum wiederum hatte andere Beschaffenheit und Ostia muss man sich angucken, das ist nicht ein grundsätzlicher Standard, das komplett flächendeckend Abwassersysteme eingerichtet wurden.
Die Römer haben das ja dann in meiner Erinnerung, ich weiß nicht viel darüber, aber ich erinnere mich so an vor allem entsprechende Technologien für ihre Garnison. Die sind ja auch über Europa hergefallen und haben dann auch vor Ort extrem abgefahrene ja eigentlich nur für den Militärbetrieb gebaute Latrinensysteme gebaut. Also was weiß ich, ich erinnere mich jetzt glaube ich gerade an England, wo die ja auch viel Badekultur, da gibt es ja auch Bath, wo ich neulich war, das war bemerkenswert, was da alles aufgebaut wurde. Aber dass man halt solche Sachen bedacht hat. Man ist dann auf einmal mit einer großen Zahl von Menschen irgendwo. Da hat man einfach dieses Problem. Und damit dann sozusagen die Soldaten nicht, salopp gesagt, in ihrer eigenen Scheiße hängen bleiben, baut man sich dann halt einfach mal eben so ein System, wo ein Bach irgendwie reingeht, einmal im Kreis da durchfegt und drüber ein Plumpsklo und fertig ist die Laube. Das ist auch sehr innovativ gewesen.
Ja ja also das Militär muss in der Ausbreitung dieser sanitären Standards, wenn Sie so wollen, eine große Rolle gespielt haben. Man hat das vermutet, auch für Ägypten, das hat eine französische Kollegin mal versucht nachzuweisen. Man hat sich immer gewundert, warum in diesen ägyptischen Dörfern nun auf einmal diese griechischen Bäder auftauchen als Standard. Und die hat das eben sehr stark mit dem Militär und den Bedürfnissen des griechischen Militärs in Verbindung gebracht. Ähnliches sieht man ganz sicherlich in den Nord-West-Provinzen. Für Lager, denken Sie an die Saalburg oder ähnliches, also gerade in permanent gebauten Lagern.
Was ist die Saalburg?
Das ist die Limeskastelle in der Nähe von Frankfurt. Eben sehr gut erhalten oder sagen wir mal wieder aufgebaut und lohnt sich sehr, wenn man verstehen will, wie so was funktioniert hat. Und es gab eben innerhalb der Lager, aber auch eben außerhalb der Lager, es gibt eben Bereiche, wo man dann solche Bäder findet, gefunden hat, und die hat man sicherlich eben für die Bequemlichkeit und die Ansprüche der Lagerbevölkerung eingerichtet. Gerade in permanenten Lagern. Also in den temporären Lagern werden sie das kaum gemacht haben. Aber in den permanenten dann schon. Und dann eben auch in den Lagervorstätten hat sich so was ausgebreitet. Und sukzessive haben sich diese Standards dann ausgebreitet.
Da macht man sich ja glaube ich immer wenig Gedanken. Ich meine wenn man so Sandalenfilme sich irgendwie anschaut und so, dann ist das immer ganz einfach, die marschieren immer irgendwohin, dann sind sie Monate unterwegs. Und ich habe mir auch schon mal so gedacht, wie ist das eigentlich so mit der sonstigen Logistik. Also wo kriegt ihr denn euer Essen her? Okay da wird halt viel geraubt. Aber allein die Logistik dieser Versorgung und natürlich dann einfach auch das Problem, da sind dann abertausende Leute auf engstem Raum, die müssen sich da ja auch irgendwie organisieren. Da sind dann solche technologischen Entwicklungen auch extrem wichtig. Also jenseits des, was haben wir denn hier für Waffen und was haben wir denn so für Kampftechniken, spielt glaube ich auch generell so diese Logistik, die sich ja offenbar dann aus diesen frühen Entwicklungen der Städte auch mitentwickelt hat, eine riesige Rolle.
ganz sicherlich. Also ich meine, die Effizienz der römischen Armee dafür waren die Römer berühmt und das wird sicherlich auch bewirkt haben, dass sie so lange erfolgreich waren in so einem großen Reich. Und die Effizienz wird auch angemessen gepriesen. Also es gibt diese berühmten Säulen des Trajan und Säule des Marcus Aurelius in Rom, die stehen beide heute noch. Es waren also Ehrenmonumente für diese beiden Kaiser, beide gute Kaiser und gerade unter Trajan hatte das römische Reich seine größte Ausdehnung. Und auf denen wird eben auf so einem Reliefspiralband die Errungenschaften der Römer zelebriert, wenn Sie so wollen. Also auch die Kriegszüge zum Teil. Aber ein ganz wesentlicher Bestandteil gerade bei Trajan ist die Leistungsfähigkeit und das technische Know-How dieser Armee. Die werden permanent da gezeigt, wie sie Brücken bauen oder wie sie Wälder roden und wie sie eben Lager anlegen und ähnliches. Und das ist auch bekannt. Also die hatten immer Ingenieure dabei, die in der Lage waren, diese Technologien da eben zu verbreiten und zu etablieren. Das war ganz klar.
Und damit hat es sich natürlich auch über ganz Europa verteilt.
Ja. Wie Monty Python, was haben uns die Römer gebracht?
Was haben sie jemals für uns getan? Jetzt hatten wir anfangs schon viel über diese Interdisziplinarität der Archäologie gesprochen, wie hat sich denn das jetzt bei Ihrer konkreten Forschung manifestiert? Mit wem haben Sie denn da so zusammengearbeitet und was hat das für Ihre Arbeit bedeutet?
Also das ist besonders offenbar in dem Pompeji-Projekt, was ein Topoi-Projekt ist. Ich habe natürlich ganz klar angefangen mit meiner Vorstellung, mich interessiert wirklich die Genese und Entwicklung dieser Badekultur da und habe klare archäologische Fragestellungen und dann aber zum Beispiel festgestellt, mit der ganzen Wasserbautechnolojgie, da bräuchte ich vielleicht doch Spezialisten und ich hatte etwa da ein Wasserbauingenieur Kai Wellbrock eingeladen. Ich habe auch vorher für die griechischen Bäder über Topoi mit berühmten Wasserbauingenieuren, etwa Herrn Fahlbusch, zusammengearbeitet und die befragt. Und Herr Wellbruck hat zum Beispiel konkret untersucht, um uns wasserbauingenieurtechnische Fragen zu beantworten. Die einfach meine Ausbildung übersteigen und ich kann sie mir jetzt auch nicht mehr anlesen, dafür habe ich keine Zeit. Und das ist sehr hilfreich, weil die einen komplett anderen Blickwinkel haben. Und gleichfalls also wiederum Wasser spielt eine große Rolle. Ich habe auch einen Studenten, der eben dazu eine Masterarbeit schreibt, haben wir zwei Kollegen aus Mainz da gehabt, ??? und ???, die haben uns Sinter analysiert.
Also die haben wirklich den Sinter, also Samples genommen, also Beispiele genommen und analysieren den für ganz neue aufregende Fragestellungen. Das ist tatsächlich Grundlagenforschung. Man weiß jetzt noch gar nicht alles, was das sagen kann, aber es geht um Fragen. Also welches Wasser haben die da genutzt aus den Tiefbrunnen. Und kann man vielleicht sogar wie bei der Dendrochronologie so Schichten ablesen, wie lang die etwas das genutzt haben. Wir haben da in der Liegewanne der Männer, beide unsere Badeanlagen haben also separate Trakte für Frauen und Männer. In der Liegewanne der Männer ganz dicke Kalkablagerungen gefunden. Und die haben wir untersuchen lassen.
Die jetzt von dem Fluss des Wassers ausgegangen sind?
Das Wasser stand in der Wanne und hat diese Kalkablagerung. Und dann hat man einmal schon sie abgeschlagen und die Wanne neu verkleidet und dann gab es wieder dicke Ablagerungen. Es sieht wirklich so aus wie so ein Baumkuchen. Und die untersuchen nun diese Schichten. Und mich interessiert, wo das Wasser herkam und ob die irgendwelche Aussagen zum Beispiel machen können darüber, wie lange man diese Wanne genutzt hat. Also das ist wirklich in Entwicklung begriffen, was diese Sinter-Analysen geben und die sind da also ganz glücklich, dass sie mit uns zusammenarbeiten. Wir haben verschiedene Tiefbrunnen und Badeanlagen und ähnliches und uns das dann angeguckt. Und da muss man regelrecht jetzt eine Datenbank aufbauen, sich also Referenzbeispiele sammeln und ich hoffe da einfach, dass wir in Zukunft weitere Aussagen davon bekommen. Und dann habe ich da auch in Pompeji mit einem Kollegen aus Oxford zusammengearbeitet, der macht in Environmental Archeology, also Umwelt-Archäologie und der untersucht uns die ganzen organischen Reste. Und der hat eine Expertise und seit 10-15 Jahren gräbt der mit ganz vielen verschiedenen Projekten, weil er sich für das Pompeji interessiert, was die klassischen Archäologen nie angeguckt haben.
Nämlich also quasi unter dem was wir heute sehen. Also geht bis weit hinunter und analysiert etwa die ganzen Vulkanausbrüche und die Siedlungsentwicklung dazwischen. Mit Hilfe der wenigen Reste, die man hat, ganz faszinierend. Und zwar eben jetzt überall in Pompeji. Da würde ich sagen … und dann arbeiten wir jetzt auch, das schwebt mir noch vor für die Zukunft, mit Architekten zusammen für spezifische Formen der 3D-Modellierung. Das hat es hier etwa mal jetzt in der Ktesifon-Ausstellung gibt es gerade im Pergamon-Museum oder auch bei der Pergamon-Ausstellung hat es das gegeben. Also inwieweit 3D-Modellierung uns helfen kann, zum Beispiel logistische Bauprozesse zu verstehen. Wir sehen in Stabianer-Thermen können wir vier große unterschiedliche Nutzungsphasen jetzt am Befund unterscheiden. Und wenn das richtig ist, müssen die mindestens bei drei die Gewölbe komplett erneuert haben. Wie man sich so was im logistischen Ablauf vorstellen kann, a) ob es tatsächlich so gewesen sein muss, b) was das eigentlich heißt für die Ausmaße und Dauer dieser Baustellen.
So was versucht man, schwebt mir jetzt mal vor, mit 3D vielleicht zu modellieren solche Prozesse. Und ich meine, wir haben dann auch literarisch zusammengearbeitet. Es gibt, das ist relativ gut erforscht, ich sage mal die literarischen Quellen zur Badekulturen und die kann man dann eben wieder für unsere Fragestellungen auch hinzuziehen.
Wie teilt man denn diese ganzen Erkenntnisse, die jetzt aus so einer Forschung heraus entstehen mit der Öffentlichkeit? Also ist so die Dokumentation auch schon so Teil der Forschung, wie viele Gedanken machen Sie sich? Was fällt dabei raus? Ich meine, das ist ja sozusagen auch immer, man will ja Wissen schaffen, das heißt auch, man muss es halt auch erhalten bzw. weitergeben oder noch zumindest leichter recherchierbar machen, als dass vielleicht in 50 Jahren wieder jemand auffällt, dass ja schon lange niemand mehr daran gearbeitet hat. Welche Rolle spielt das, wie bauen Sie das in Ihre Arbeit ein?
Naja Podcast.
Deswegen sitzen wir heute hier. Auf ganz unterschiedlichen Ebenen. Erst mal ganz traditionell, dem fühle ich mich im Moment wirklich noch verpflichtet, auch aus den Gründen, die ich Ihnen eingangs genannt hatte, werden wir eine Grabungspublikation machen. Also wir haben schon publiziert teilweise in den üblichen also Konferenzbänden und ähnlichem. Aber für die republikanischen Thermen gibt es sicherlich eine Monografie. für den Bau in Morgantina ganz genauso. Also ganz traditionelle Form, wie Monografie und Artikel in auch Peer-Revue-Journals. Das ist ganz wichtig denke ich für die Wissenschaft. Darüber hinaus macht man also … ich habe ein großes Interesse daran, meine Forschungen der Öffentlichkeit zu vermitteln. Ob das jetzt Führungen vor Ort sind, wenn wir da sind, dann teilen wir Leuten das mit. Oder man versucht eben in Zeitungen Interviews zu geben, wenn Interesse besteht. Oder hat eben online seine ganzen Berichte in anschaulicher Form parat.
Hervorragende Wahl.
Aber neue Formen, die mir vorschweben, das ist auch etwas wiederum was Topoi bietet. Die haben also diese e-Topoi eingerichtet und auch so ein neues System von Datenbanken, die scitable sind, ganz aufregende neue Online-Publikationsform und da wollen wir versuchen, einen Teil unserer Sachen, wir können nicht alles in dieses Buch packen. Das ist ein Nachteil des digitalen Zeitalters, Sie generieren so viele Daten, Sie können die gar nicht alle anständig verwalten. Geschweige denn wollen und können Sie die Öffentlichkeit damit überfluten. Wir haben tausende von Fotos. Da muss man natürlich eine sinnvolle Auswahl treffen. Und der Herr Grashoff, der das quasi ins Leben gerufen hat, diese ganzen neuen Online-Publikationsformen da und der Spiritus Rector sage ich mal, mit dem haben wir eben diskutiert, dass man zum Beispiel ein Teil der Photogrammetrien, wenn Sie wirklich von jeder Wand eine Aufnahme machen, was ich wichtig finde, was für die Dokumentation wichtig ist.
Wir haben die auch erst mal gereinigt, jetzt überwuchern die wieder. Wir haben die in einem Zustand, wie die selten wieder sein werden, dass man so was als ein Scitable-Eintrag in so eine Datenbank macht. Das kann dann jeder angucken und aufrufen. Und dann gibt es im Moment auch noch keine Begrenzungen der Zahl der Fotos. Uns liegt schon dran, einen Teil zumindest dieses Fotoarchivs, was wir generiert haben, tatsächlich der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich zu machen. Aber dann auch in einer Form, wo kein Schindluder damit getrieben werden kann. Ich stelle es jetzt nicht in Wikipedia ein, sondern eben in eine seriöse Datenbank, wo das gewissermaßen hingehört. Und da sind wir auch den italienischen Behörden, der Supraindentenz verpflichtet, diese verschiedenen Publikationsformen auszuloten. Die wollen ganz sicherlich von uns die Monografie. Und für die ist ganz sicherlich aufregend, wenn wird diese scitables machen. Und wenn wir es mal schaffen, 3D-modelle zu generieren, das ist immer der letzte Schritt natürlich in der Auswertung, dann liegt mir auch daran, die einer Öffentlichkeit zugänglich zu machen. Das bieten eben diese e-Topoi-Sachen auch.
Also einer Öffentlichkeit im Sinne von einer interessanten Laienöffentlichkeit oder im Sinne einer wissenschaftlichen Öffentlichkeit, also der Weitergabe der eigentlichen Forschungsdaten zwecks als Basis für andere Forschung.
Beides. Also ich meine beides. Also die ganzen Sachen sind ja der Öffentlichkeit auch zugänglich. Die Frage ist, ob sie nochmal eigene Websites dafür einrichten. Wir hatten am Anfang bei der ersten Grabungskammer, den republikanischen Thermen hatten wir regelrecht eine Pressekonferenz in Italien, da haben die auch Filme gedreht, das haben die bei sich auf die Websites eingestellt. Da ist für mich immer die Frage, wo und wie kreiere ich eigene Websites und dann finde ich es fasst günstiger, wenn die Öffentlichkeit eben über diese wissenschaftlichen Websites auf so was Zugriff bekommt. Sonst ist wieder die Frage, wer verwaltet das, wo tu ich das hin? Wie lange ist das für so eine Öffentlichkeit zugänglich? Also ich denke, dass die Medien heute durchaus geeignet sind, beide gleichermaßen zu bedienen.
Die …
Ich meine, ich könnte auch einen Wikipedia-Eintrag zu den republikanischen Thermen machen. Ich möchte auch gar nicht ausschließen, dass man den macht, das wäre eben eine Möglichkeit. Dann wäre es tatsächlich, kann man andenken, kann man bieten.
Ich meine, Schindluder fand ich ein schönes Wort in dem Zusammenhang mit Wikipedia.
Nein gar nicht. Ich bin gar nicht, mittlerweile muss ich sagen gibt es sehr gute Einträge. Wikipedia halte ich für sehr wichtig.
Ja klar, die aber auch nur dann sozusagen gut werden, wenn dann eben auch Forscher sich selber sozusagen betätigen und es nicht dritten oder weniger informierten überlassen. Von daher ist es ja durchaus eine Outline, aber Wikipedia ist ja jetzt im Prinzip nur so eine Art Magazin. Also man erklärt Dinge, wie sie im Zusammenhang sind, man schreibt halt einen Artikel. Das ist halt sozusagen eine Sicht auf die Dinge. Für die Wissenschaft viel interessanter ist ja, sozusagen auch an die Daten ranzukommen und das eben in möglichst strukturierter Form. Also nicht nur so, hier haben wir da mal ein paar Fotos gemacht, sondern man muss das ja auch ganz klar klassifizieren und einordnen. Es muss eine Systematik auch in den Daten selber geben. Gibt es da einen Trend in der Archäologie, dass man sagt, okay es gibt hier eine Standardisierung der digitalen Erfassung von archäologischer Forschung?
Oh ja. Also der bildet sich im Moment gerade aus. Was ich eben sagte, diese scitable-Database, ich denke das ist die Zukunft, weil die eine hohe Qualität in den Daten, also mit 3D-Fotos und so weiter gewährleistet und eben aber seriös wissenschaftlich ist. Das heißt Sie müssen das zitieren regelrecht und dann haben Sie aber auch die Gewähr, dass das von einem wissenschaftlichen Autor exakt so abgesegnet ist. Und in Wikipedia das steht und fällt mit den Autoren. Die Autoren sind aber nicht kenntlich, das heißt Sie wissen nicht, ob es ein Wissenschaftler geschrieben hat. Und selbst wenn ich jetzt den Eintrag zu Republican-Bath mache, dann weiß ich ja nicht, ob hinterher jemand anders mir den verändert. Das ist das was ich meine, das ist das Risiko. Und ein anderes Problem und das muss man auch klipp und klar benennen, jetzt vielleicht weniger für mich, ich habe meine Professur, aber für die junge Generation, wir hatten gerade die Diskussion. Ich hatte mehrere amerikanische Kollegen eingeladne über Topoi und die Berlin Graduated School of Ancient Studies und haben exakt dieses Problem diskutiert.
Für prominente italienische Grabungen, also amerikanische Grabungen in Italien, wo alles nur noch online ist. Sie müssen als junger Forscher publizieren und es muss mit Ihrem Namen verbunden sein. Es kostet unglaublich viel Zeit, diese ganzen online 3D-digitalen Sachen zu generieren. Jetzt stellen Sie die großzügig ein und haben Ihre ganze Nachwuchswissenschaftlerkarriere dafür verbraucht, aber keine nachweisbare Publikation, dann machen Sie keine wissenschaftliche Karriere. Das ist ein Problem, was noch gelöst werden muss bei vielen. Und das finde ich hat eben e-Topoi ganz gut gelöst. Sie sind der Autor, Sie sind ein identifizierbarer Autor für bestimmte Einträge. Das muss so sein. Man muss gewissermaßen die wissenschaftliche Leistung namentlich anerkennen müssen, damit man damit auch eben in Zukunft Jobs kriegt.
Aber ist das nicht ein interessanter Punkt, dass sozusagen … ich meine angenommen ich fahr jetzt dahin, schaue mir irgendwie 100 Bäder an. Ich erfasse die, ich erblicke auf wesentliche und dann erbringe ich auch noch diese Leistung dieser Digitalisierung, und zwar nicht irgendwie nur, naja ich habe jetzt hier digitale Fotos gemacht und stelle die mal ins Netz, sondern eine strukturierte nach so einem Klassifizierungsmechanismus, auf den man sich geeinigt hat oder den man vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang auch erst noch weiterentwickelt und stelle das online. Ist das nicht auch schon eine wissenschaftliche Leistung?
Das ist eine wissenschaftliche Leistung ganz sicherlich. Aber wieder die Frage ist, also Sie müssen quasi eine eigene Website generieren. Dann ist die Frage, das kann man heute problemlos machen, das machen ja auch viele private Leute. Aber die Frage ist, wie ist die wissenschaftlich anerkannt diese Website? Ist die abgesegnet? Wie haben Sie die Gewähr? Wie können Sie klar machen, dass das zitierfähig und korrekt ist? Was sind die wissenschaftlichen Standards, wie sind die da generiert? Und wer garantiert mir, dass die in 10 Jahren, wenn sie dann für Tenure irgendwie sich bewerben, auch noch überhaupt zu sehen ist diese Website? Also da sind schon noch fundamentale Probleme. Und ein anderes großes Problem, das darf man bei uns nicht ignorieren, sind die Copyright-Rechte und die Genehmigungen. Sie könnten nicht einfach überall hingehen und was abfotografieren und einstellen. Das machen zwar viele, aber als Wissenschaftler können Sie es nicht.
Copyright von was?
Naja Sie gehen mal irgendwohin und dann ist da eine unpublizierte Grabung und Sie denken, wunderbar, da mache ich jetzt mal so ein Foto und dann stelle ich das mal ein. Das können Sie als Tourist meinetwegen machen, das ist dann auch nicht korrekt. Aber wenn Sie das als Wissenschaftler machen und darüber dann auch noch schreiben, was Ihre Kollegen gerade ausgegraben haben, das geht nicht. Also Sie müssen korrekte wissenschaftliche Praxis, auch gerade für diese ganzen Online-Publikationen genauso wahren. Alles das sind wirklich fundamentale Probleme, die man im Moment versucht zu lösen. Und ich glaube, einer alleine kann die nicht lösen, da brauchen Sie wirklich große Organisationen für.
Eine Frage, ich denke hier muss es auf einen Konsens hinauslaufen. Dass wir uns da richtig verstehen. Also was ich feststelle und ich grübel auch schon die ganze Zeit, weil wir das hier auch schon in 1-2 Gesprächen auch schon mal ähnlich thematisiert haben. Wir haben derzeit einen etablierten Blick darauf, was wissenschaftliche Arbeit ist. Und die macht sich halt extrem daran fest, da wird halt geforscht und dann gibt es ein Forschungsergebnis und dann wird publiziert und das ist die wissenschaftliche Arbeit so. Das ist der Maßstab, an dem heute gearbeitet wird, diese Publikation. Man stellt bloß jetzt in zunehmendem Maße fest, dass es wichtige wertvolle Arbeiten gibt, die nicht unbedingt jetzt in diesem altbekannten Kanon abbildbar ist, die aber trotzdem für die Wissenschaft als solche einen erheblichen Wert darstellt.
Und ich sage jetzt mal, Datenaufbereitung, also Datenbereitstellung ist sagen wir mal eine Kunst, mindestens eine Disziplin, die ein hohes Verständnis erfordert. Da muss man extrem fundiert sein und vielleicht eben auch wissenschaftsübergreifend, das ist ja unabhängig von Archäologie, sich mit Datenformaten, Archivierung, Strukturen, Datenstrukturen, Bereitstellung, Protokollen etc. Verschmelzbarkeit, Versionierung, all diese ganzen Fragestellungen, die ja bei der Archivierung, das haben wir ja hier auch schon teilweise angesprochen, mit aufkommen. Und in einem ähnlichen Bereich, ich glaube, darum drehte sich auch das Gespräch, wo ich mich gerade versucht habe dran zu erinnern, Visualisierung. Also auch das ist ja nicht unbedingt etwas, was man jetzt so per sé erlernt, oder auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt so erwarten kann, dass das jeder kann. Aber wir wissen auch, dass wissenschaftliche Arbeit eben mit Visualisierung gut arbeitet. Jetzt sind das so Beiwerke vielleicht manchmal einer Publikation, aber müssten wir nicht eigentlich eher da hingehen.
Dass man sagt, okay zusätzlich zu dieser klassischen Erkenntnisgewinnforschung gibt es auch einfach handwerkliche Arbeiten, die aber tatsächlich eigentlich einen ähnlichen Stellenwert haben, weil da fließt viel Wissen rein, da muss man selber gut gebildet sein. Man muss ein hohes wissenschaftliches Verständnis an sich mitbringen, um überhaupt eine Visualisierung zu machen oder auch um eine Datenarchivierung oder damit eine Weiterleitung zu machen, dass man diese Disziplin im Prinzip innerhalb des wissenschaftlichen Systems, ich sage mal gleichberechtigt aufstellt und sagt, auch das ist genauso eine wissenschaftliche Leistung, so dass sich diese Frage mit, naja dann habe ich ja sozusagen als Wissenschaftler noch nichts getan, wenn ich nur meine Daten bereitstelle, dass man das eben genau anders sieht. Dass man sagt, da hat man schonmal was getan. Weil das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall auch eine Leistung.
Ja und nein. Also erstens hat es das immer gegeben. zum Beispiel wenn sie Keramik behandelt haben, haben sie immer gezeichnet, sie haben das immer visualisiert. Archäologen haben immer quasi, also arbeiten mindestens dual. Also ein großer Bestandteil ist Text, der andere ist immer die Visualisierung. So haben wir immer gelebt. Und die Deutschen haben da eine ausgewiesene Expertise und Tradition, bis hin zu den Publikationen exzellentester Art. Fotos, Zeichnungen, Schnittzeichnungen, Rekonstruktionszeichnungen. Wir haben ein eigenes Fach, was Bauforschung heißt, was eben in höchster Qualität das immer bereitgestellt hat, immer schon 3D, halt nur gezeichnet. Ob Sie es von Hand machen oder am Computer spielt da zunächst keine Rolle. Das heißt die Tradition ist da und es war immer Bestandteil gerade bei den Bauforschern auch, diese handwerkliche erkenntnisgeleitete Fähigkeit war immer also sehr wichtig und wurde anerkannt. Ja unbenommen. Und wie gesagt, ob Sie das jetzt eben dann mit einer scitable-Datenbank machen oder anders, spielt für mich überhaupt keine Rolle.
Was für mich eine Rolle spielt ist, also wenn jemand kommt, wie gesagt, ich bin Sprecherin von so einer Graduate-School und da kommt jetzt jemand mit einem Proposal, ja ich mach da mal ein 3D-Modell von XY. Dann sage ich, ja und so what? Das reicht nicht. Und das ist der Trend heute. Für mich muss immer eine klipp und klare wissenschaftliche Fragestellung da sein. Wenn Sie mir sagen, ah ich mach mal ein 3D-Modell eben von den Stabianer-Thermen oder von irgendsoeiner Basilika, dann sage ich, ich weiß grundsätzlich wie so die römischen Thermen aussehen und eine Basilika. Ich muss wissen, warum machen Sie das und was soll mir das wissenschaftlich bringen? Für die generelle Öffentlichkeit wunderbar nett, gibt es tolle Websites kann ich Ihnen sagen von spanischen Thermen, irre. Ich muss aber wissen, was die Wissenschaft davon profitiert. Die Dokumentation, ob das 3D oder 2D im Buch oder einer Website ist, als solche hat es nie gereicht bei uns im Fach und wird auch in Zukunft nicht reichen und darf auch nicht reichen.
Wenn man das sozusagen nur unter diesem Aspekt des sich anschauen Könnens behandelt kann ich das nachvollziehen. Aber in dem Moment, wo man sagt, ich schaffe jetzt hier Datenmaterial, was explizit darauf ausgelegt ist und damit eben auch gewissen Standards entspricht, um als Grundlage weiterer Forschung zu dienen.
Aber das haben wir immer schon gemacht. Ich meine gut, das hat es in der Archäologie auch immer schon gegeben. Es hat immer Kataloge gegeben, die waren solider Grundlagenforschungsnatur und vielleicht ich sage mal so synthetisch analytisch erkenntnismager oder nicht im vordergründigen Interesse. Das hat immer gegolten, damit haben Sie meinetwegen auch einen Job bekommen. Das hat es immer gegeben, weil spezifische handwerkliche Fähigkeiten notwendig sind im Fach und auch in Zukunft notwendig sind. Dann haben andere die vielleicht für aufregendere Fragestellungen hergenommen, das ist auch legitim, in diesem Sinne ja. Die aufregende Forschung wird in der Kombination von beiden gemacht, sage ich Ihnen. Es wird glaube ich immer alles geben müssen. Aber sukzessive fällt leider die Finanzierung dieser mehr handwerklichen Sachen weg. Das wird immer weniger honoriert. Da kriegen Sie keine Drittmittelprojekte mit und da kriegen Sie auch keine Stellen mit.
Auch wenn Sie diese Leute - ich erkenn's an - brauchen. Aber Sie brauchen eigentlich auch schon immer irgendwie die faszinierende Fragestellung im Hintergrund.
Wie sieht es denn jetzt so aus mit der Zukunft der Archäologie? Wir haben ja schon gesehen, was sich alles verändert hat. Gibt es weitere vor der Tür stehende technologische Entwicklungen, wo sich ablesen lässt, dass dort noch mal ein grundsätzlicher Wandel oder Vorsprung erreicht werden kann, den man so bisher noch nicht hatte?
Oh Gott, ob man das alles immer selber überblickt, wenn man gerade mitten drin ist. Also ich glaube der Ausbau dieser ganzen 3D digitalen Dokumentation das ist noch etwas, wo sicherlich ein Erkenntnisgewinn zu verbuchen ist. Vor allen Dingen darin, wenn Sie eben hingehen und alle Daten sofort systematisch in so eine GIS-Datenbank zum Beispiel reintun. GIS-Systeme, wo Sie versuchen alle Daten holistisch kombiniert nachprüfbar zu verbinden. Das haben manche Grabungen als Standard, noch längst nicht alle.
Geoinformationssysteme.
Genau. Das haben längst noch nicht alle, weil das wirklich wie gesagt auch wirklich ein technisch finanzielles Problem ist. Sie müssen erstmal die ganze Logistik und das Know-How und die Leute haben. Aber da, wenn man nachmodellieren kann, präzise wie der Grabungsprozess gelaufen ist und das in Zukunft auswerten kann, das könnte sehr spannend werden. DNA-Analysen hatte ich Ihnen schon genannt, ich glaube das ist eine große Sache der Zukunft. Wenn man sehr viel systematischen das zahlreiche Material, was man hat, auf diese Fragestellungen hin untersucht. Alle diese naturwissenschaftlichen Methoden, die sich weiterentwickeln, ich sagte die Sinter-Analyse, da sind wir am Anfang. Wir wissen überhaupt noch nicht, was die eigentlich in Zukunft alles bringen kann. Marmoranalysen, Datenbanken von Marmoranalysen. Ich glaube das bringt die neue Technologie, dass man große Materialdatenbanken aufbauen kann für eben Referenzen, die man eigentlich braucht, und die man im Moment noch nicht hat. Das ist schwierig für einen Wissenschaftler alleine, da müssten eigentlich alle immer zusammenarbeiten, das klappt auch nicht weltweit oder zumindest mediterranweit, wie sie sich das so wünschen.
Aber da der Umgang eben mit vielen Daten, das ist sicherlich für die Zukunft vielversprechend, wenn man so was leisten kann.
Ja Frau Trümper, ich glaube jetzt haben wir hier unsere Reise durch die archäologische Forschung erst mal ganz gut zurückgelegt.
Ja ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich, dass Sie mich durch diese Reise geführt haben.
Ja ich bedanke mich auch. Und ich bedanke mich auch wie immer bei allen, die hier zugehört haben und sage, was ich immer sage, nämlich dass es hier bald weitergeht und bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.